un switch bonsoir fab c'est plus dur que
sa vie future
en fait je vous avais tu peux ouais
c'est un yo qui est différent quoi c'est
pas le seul youtube ces yachts which ton
un peu froid tu trouve le gros twin ou
alors un tout il s'est lancé quoi bon
bah écoute et aux experts en forme
nous on est chaud patate de chez moi on
est chaud surtout toi d'ailleurs
ouais ben moi j'ai une chose tout court
je me console c'est parti déjà courte
c'est déjà partir de la tension est en
train d'arriver la parole c'est pour
l'exciter se met ces partis aux quatre
approuvent est parti le pour combien de
temps la de cinq minutes
mais avant je comprends pas ok c'est bon
j'ai attendu à 90 minutes 90 minutes
match de foot quoi
ouais pour commencer un c'est
l'échauffement allez hop c'est bon je
suis la femme qui est en train d'arriver
de partout je suis en train de sortir le
chat et je suis parti ils nous ont
enlevé pour la première fois on est déjà
216 les mecs il va falloir je vais
mettre des liens de partage il va forme
partagée ce à deux partout les mecs
sains on vise les 1000 voilà je sais pas
ce qu'on vise femmes mais on l'on vise
on vise à aller plus haut des dacquois
ça ne te fait pas peur non pas toujours
le poing levé
ouais mais je pense que à l'usure
dominguez il va pas y croire très
longtemps tu vois je pense que vous
pensez un beau score de nouvelles ce
soir ouais avant avant avant le quart de
finale où on sera un peu en sueur parce
qu'on devrait rencontrer si on se
qualifie il faut pas mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs
il faut pas eu d'accord vous vendre la
peau de l'ours avant de l'avoir tué
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre que
l'expression mais en tout cas un monde
autre que tu ne la vends pas quoi il
faut que le dit oui on va dépasser par m
c'est le but que fortnight en sueur quoi
aller partager moi le truc facebook que
j'ai mis sur le chat là c'est un nouveau
lien cod a partagé une fois vous
repartager quoi on partage de partout et
on défonce dans qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire sur cette position fab ben ça fait
d'une berlinois trident tiberi masculine
à cannes des 3 et dominguez jeu avec des
6 rue du fossé 5 pourrait très souvent
qui possible et en gros notre position
symétrique mais juste des noirs maison
at il des cinq tomes john petites cibles
ou blanc donc c'est pour ça qu'on est il
m'a fait à 4 la part end la terre étant
27 cartons près je sais ça l'europe sans
la target mariette cible tard et à cible
en espagnol quoi tu pensais plutôt la
cible oui c'est le vrai espagnol d'antan
quoi l'espagnol littéraire de rue lopez
here is it as de bons mais c'est assez
symétrique tout sa femme quand même 1
malgré tout et ça va être difficile à
percer ouais ouais bien sûr mais c'est
léger plus que pour le moment je pense
alors plus le truc
le truc à savoir fax et que l'algorithme
ils pensent que dominguez est légèrement
favori en 5 + 2 à l'algorithme il te dit
dominguez plus fort en 5 + 2 un peu
moins fort en 3 + 2 et qui va se faire
défoncer dû l'être
après moi je ne sais pas tu as faim
c'est c'est l'algorithme donc d'après
l'algorithme tu as ça peut être un match
qui va avoir un scénario plus
intéressant entre guillemets que
d'autres matches qu'on a view c'est un
massacre direct parce que si dominguez
venait à gagner en cinq plus où tu vois
il serait pas démoraliser n'aura pas une
petite remontée avec ses presque
nous menons des tu vas tomber 5 pour
venir s'en prendre à l' p honey sassine
quoi ouais mais peut-être toi tu es fou
à 4.5 français 6 tourcoing fou prend 1,8
cavalli produit par des preneurs même si
tu repères aux cinq je crois pas que tu
es très envie de faire ça avec les
blancs peut-être tour à st de joie vous
tombez sainte anne
il a réfléchi et un truc mais dominent
les i
enfin tu as même si elles veulent il est
très très bon calcul et où dominguez
faut pas oublier qu'il a éliminé coup
sur coup meilleur ça tu vas pas facile
et après il éliminer amr pour en arriver
là comme un crime c'est une autre
dimension
ouais mais tu as dominguez j'ai envie de
te dire c'est pas c'est pas la real
sociedad où le sporting gijon tu vois
maryvonne et non plus mais génère par là
et que toi c'est pas comme l'an dernier
quand avait dû grigorian ce que tu avais
du meilleur fin tu vois là c'est quand
même c'est un con quand même un cran au
dessus mais qui a été champion du monde
de beach suis assez bas selon vous
présentez vite fait oui dominique est
donc ce joueur je sais pas quelle eau et
dallas mais un truc comme 2736 l'a déjà
été sûrement autour de 1760 un très bon
joueur alors le voit moins adroit de
l'élite
il s'impose converti des seconds caruana
et petite info pour vous il va se faire
naturaliser américain que dans une
prochaine compétition où il jouera avec
les états unis mais ça va venir
ouais alors après attention parce que tu
as ta tâche en deux clans sont classés
en fait ces cinq joueurs que enfin
d'autres genres capitula remplaçants ils
pourront tous tourné court le plus
faible sera donné cette 125 enfants
sachant que la lave qui a perdu une
deuxième partie aujourd'hui une bonne
partie de l'offre on pourra peut-être
faire en vidéo avec une très belle
tactique à la fin de le il a perdu
contrôle le comblerait ici joue il faut
un truc à saint louis où je passe et en
chine dangereux dans les gens chez nous
bah ouais si j'en paye un peu le prix
qua non mais bien souvent enfin passer
par les tops jours elles ont des lois
normales mais t'as pas mal de joueurs
chinois qui joue que là bas et qui sont
vraiment sous-évalué mais c'est un
plaisir de jouer contre h max un ferme
et saint ferme est un méta beaucoup
joueurs vous jouez à billets ben c'est
insupportable aux yeux bleus c'est
dangereux pour le vélo alors françoise
accueilli attention maxime s'endort
alors pas vraiment parce qu'ils allaient
blanc oui mais ok vous savez il ya du il
ya du rajout celui 5 +25 cuisin
attention en plus un bon donc c'est
normalement tout en bas bon après quand
tu as plus qu'une seconde c'est chaud
quand même mais c'est moins grave en
fait d'un retard au temps quand un
rajout que compte à part
après je préfère qu'on soit devant
autant que derrière parce que contre
maxime tu as le jeu dans le petit
périmètre
le taux plein il peut
il peut il peut être quand même très
dangereux dans le petit périmètre maxime
j'ai mis dehors des caméras des joueurs
à l'écran l'envoi maxime qui est très
concentré mais il bâille tout en restant
concentré quoi bon est ce que le fait
d'avoir joué bien avant ça peut être un
handicap dans le sens où étais tu es un
peu fatigué du tournoi ou d'un autre
côté tu es chaud basse et des deux têtes
de ces vins du rhône dont on prend le
commentaire en fonction à la fin du
match près comme l'exemple sportif
c'était un bon échauffement ou non en
fait non donc on était trop fatigué en
fait il on ne sait pas je vais pas la
cadence se prononcera qu'après deux
matches de ce qu'il prend à ses quatre
peut-être pour jouer sur un ton cloyes
je continue à avancer mais je sais pas
si c'est si par ces quatre ce que ça
qu'après si t'as rien à faire
concrètement
c'est une faiblesse c'est une partie de
manoeuvre fable pour le moment je n'aime
pas trop le fait que les fous de cases
blanches et disparus dans le sens où une
pion à 6 c'est plus vraiment une cible
et les cavaliers f3 et g3 lecavalier
décider vraiment impérial tu vois le
blog de la position ouais bah il tient
là car en fait s'il est un lecavalier g3
tout en ayant de l'action ces captures
j'ai l'impression qu'à l'idée de et g3
tu as ils sont fous chasser un cavalier
des six qua non mais là oui je le
deviens énarques sont pas mal du tout
peut-être même pu faire un truc comme un
geste simple mais assez pragmatique
c'est en train de faire de bing asie il
envoie lit double les tours sur la
colonne b une colonne il le prend non
non il est pas mal dominés gaz il faut
dire qu il envoie le ccac ça y est il
tente un peu de dynamiser tout ça c'est
vrai que tu as passif tu veux un peu
souffrir bon alors après on peut aussi
jouer un truc comme ces 6es avec les
noirs je veux dire par là que lecavalier
des six est protégée si jamais mais bon
il fait tourner quatre voies la galère
bien meilleur en baisse un travail
d'invention que maxime va nous faire un
tour de magie laïque seewald tu vas tu
vas le magouilles et le prix qu'il est
juste tellement confiant quand je
commente maxime sauf contre nacac
mais maxime paraît tellement au dessus
en tactique il a échangé le sait
maintenant après je pense pas qu'il ait
un complexe d'infériorité en 2000 guest
tu vois non mais bon joueur un des gros
tournois
j'ai pas de raison et attention option à
5 5
mike hayes c6 qu'ils aient baissé d'un
ça arrive oui puis les chants fin
j'avais été champions de la caf 1 j'ai
envie de te dire même si maxime est
beaucoup plus fort tu as tu te dis j'ai
été champion du monde toi non pas après
sur le maxi mais plus fort à ce que des
champions que tu es plus fort et quelque
part par un toi ça te donne forcément
c'est bien sur le cv ça te donne une
confiance à tu sais que tu peux le faire
peut être débattu des mecs bon à cette
cadence
pourquoi pas après les tuera pas de le
battre une fois pas dire c'est un match
très long
il est donc sur ces cinq et on imagine
ni veut faire khalid 17e attaque à la
fois à 5 et 6 mai se fait pas pour
regarder les deux envie même si tu fais
un truc comme kirby et ses 4 tu défends
à 5,7 a que 5
il va défendre à cassis ya patassé 5 qui
sauteront du coup je crois qu'il se
résigne à perm un pion mais au moins ils
activent le roi mais répondait mal on va
la tenir pas même la femme ne sais pas
c'est pas envie qu'on laisse le cubain
prendre confiance dans ce match femme ma
personne en vie non mais tu vois si on
le laisse s'installer après enfin
naturel c'est comme on a dit que le mec
qui a été championne du monde et où il
va pas tu vois il baissera pas le cas le
sont pas ce que je veux dire non alors
il va rénover ses copains fous peut-être
on laisse doubler les pions et paresse
et des guenons meilleur faire caillasser
5 cet horrible ait quoi que il le fait
mais bon non moi je crois qu'ils offrent
bah ouais t'es telesis après tout en
même temps et d'espacé genre de double
attaque assez dégueu fab france et 423
qui existe partout et 6 3
il a totalement a regretté un pion thème
j'ai peur sinon hockey bien plus trop de
temps
non ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre
monsieur au mieux pour maxime pour
éventuellement à marquer ça les
problèmes de temps c'est un genre de
programme plantez c'est un problème
dynamique et forcément ça favorise le
joueur qui est moins bien
d'ailleurs c'est clément il ya des
cavaliers de partout quoi c'est horrible
bondi dans tous les sens après le point
positif quant à kelly contre kiteloop à
32 fourchette entre le patronat réclame
2011 rapide s'il atteint les 6 e 3 e
vers maxime qui est en train de jeu j'ai
cinq noms mais ça sarlac encore face à
face à max gagne pas je me dise même
iris à paris de florette ou taper sans
ne rien perdre quelque part ou alors
faire un match qui a valu aux six
matches non me menace qui est aussi ce
matin mais ça peut se gagner fab serait
fantastique
ça te met un petit coup au moral ça va
perdre mais ça y est je pense dominguez
qui joue vite moi c'est de bouffer les
seconds un peu de trouver un plan bien
parce que ouais c'est pas facile d une
seconde île et bouffe pas quoi non non
mais la maxime il fait du gros travail
de raser sans faille de sa part un
blocus des fantômes tu sais plus quoi
pousser parce qu'on pousse cgt il
échangea une paire de carrière ça lui
faciliter la vie sa main ok dommage de
revenir mais la décence c'était chaud
un autre opposant st bo femmes il a bien
joué s'est trompé sur légèrement
inférieur il l'a remonté tranquille bien
bien je l'air mais non mais c'est beau
les échecs quand ces jeux comme ça par
la fia c'était une belle partie je
reviens pas eu de gaffe n'ont pas pu y
ait du suspense
bon c'est un double enquête oh ouais
donc maxime je crois qu'en général ils
jouent plutôt avec ses 5 dans ce système
un peu trois caps qui joue la jeune
femme me contre 3,2 pas trop c'est pas
terrible
et du coup c'est tout un système anti
greenwald de par des blancs mais aux
maximois je les ai vus se l'est jouée
double franchetto soit joué que c'est
simple une sorte de benoni voulait
blanche veut 3 nous irons défendre un
temps - c'est pas ta brisage cueilli
c'est que la première vraie mais ça
donne le ton d'un match voilà prendre
avez vu je crois le fin on n'a pas vu je
suis comme ça soa et choix que les
concerts permettent de première et puis
après les calmes rasé contre oui même
deux points d'écart après 1h30 de jeu ce
serait rien ça se montrent surtout que
maxime va être beaucoup plus fort en
bullet time you run puisses moins 25 30
parties de jouées mais bon finalement se
situe peut écraser le match c'est
toujours mieux de le faire
1 0 c'est pas pareil que 0,1 mais bon ça
va c'est pas si loin des 0 2 ce sera pas
pareil que 2 0
mais bon là ça va la position a l'air
correct fab frêche parue dans le
quotidien verbe b3ppo sait faire c'est
simple quand même un peu plus d'espacé
un meilleur football et non c'est
simplement tabriz à je suis noir est ce
que sur le match n'a califano si c'était
un peu la même chose que vous à quelque
chose près ce que est ce que nakaya la
première puis il fan a réussi à remonter
quoi c'est la non là
non mais dominguez c'est beaucoup plus
fort que l'oif and fire c'est pas la
même galaxie quoi c'est pas le même
niveau quoi après il fallait joue très
bien elle est beaucoup plus fort que
femme et moi mais géré par la ce et
passer une autre classe
c'est un peu comme si je fais jouer
federer ou enfin on va dire un genre
demeurer un truc comme ça contre un mec
du top 50 mondial
ok sur un match qui peut perdre mais ici
le fait jouer contre le numéro 401 fin
au gaz même si elle est plus floue 400
me mais rennes je consens 50e mondiale
fallait les différences faites c'est au
tennis t'as pas besoin d'aller aussi
loin parce qu'il n'ya pas de ma partie
nulle en fait très vite un gros écart
noire causés chaque commis l annuler
c'est moins flagrant tu vois à la longue
sur un match de speech à son bateau va
se voir mais sur une partie ou 2 tu peux
tenir le choc et je pense aussi que dans
les sports qui sont très populaires
comme le foot le tennis et tout ça les
écarts se resserrent à force
jaro foot aujourd'hui à moins d'écart
entre enfin en gros toutes les équipes
peuvent gagner ou perdre gérer à
l'époque il ya 40 ans ce n'était pas le
cas car c'était carnage tout temps et au
rugby au greffier au rugby avant aussi
ces carnages tout le temps et maintenant
tu as même que le japon ils peuvent
créer des surprises ou quoi alors
qu'avant c'était carnage et je pense que
dans tous les sports quand l'histoire
devient assez populaire il ya beaucoup
plus de participants et les niveaux se
resserre et aux échecs les niveaux sont
pas encore méga serrer la main faire
gaffe ou des deux camps ya peut-être un
modèle sans faire et je vois genre fou
des deux tours de 1.56
l'un des nouveaux qui sont le tchad
bienvenue à vous vous êtes en train de
suivre un match un match d'une
compétition peut égaliser
parce que la peinture prend 1,4 je pense
que maxime veut garder le bordel et
c'est de l'arnaqué quand même non
peut-être mais bon avec trois pions
compte trois sur la même bonne chance
mais bon ça avec les cavaliers blanc
sont peut-être pas au tac le cadet à 5
un peu à la bande qui n'ont pas
satisfait non mais bon faut quand même
faire un peu gaffe tu peux te faire
quelle gentille c'est pas si simple même
je pense de tel joueur ça va mon coeur
que j'ai eus pourrait se braquer vous
avez vu une partie timan kasparov un peu
comme ça il est plus que des pions d'un
côté mais plein de pièces partout où tu
connais un peu les pièces là bas la lda
s'est mal finie et on espère que je veux
4,5
brière a par ailleurs elle est trouvable
leurs 85 voyage pas trop mais là s'il
veut tout était bon il peut faire tour
et 8 échecs et tout liquider ses voeux
par contre pour huit tours prend
cavaliers prends je pense nuls
automatique non après caruana on a perdu
une comme ça raconte rené accart ya pas
longtemps
ouais ouais mais là encore plus simple
ce sermon 3 les autres c'était 84,1 déjà
c'était très nul
alors est-ce que la stratégie pour
dominguez ces deux-là joué pendant
quelques coups pour faire un tour d une
chrono fabre je crois que c'était trop
tôt pour jouer et surtout qu'apparemment
ce haka danse fétiche l'appétit cheveux
je ne sais pas mais c'est peut-être là
la cadence à laquelle il a le plus de
chances qu'il faut qu'il sait d'exposer
s'il ya un truc à creuser on sait qu'en
bullet à la fin on trace de mal se
passer pour lui alors autant essayer
d'avoir un matelas van houtte et maxime
s'est fait un nom
et de qui ce que ça l'udc estime keith
quinn qu'on connaît un qui secoue vraie
rencontre à genève femmes ouais et max
et c'est la variante dont tu parlais
fabriquer des lavandes pas les préparer
et les normes euro5 où ils vont faire un
sang neuf au prochain je pense c'est ce
qu'on peut l'appeler avant bbf si je ne
te ferai pas l'injure fab france vraie
bombe au jeu amateur je n'ai toujours
pas joué on a parlé donc quelque part là
les warrants trail le nom de la paire
premières personnes qui m'ont
apparemment ok maxime et savez faire un
truc que j'ai déjà fait sans grand
succès c'est de t'ouvrir la colonne h
mais en fait même sa belle et même si tu
es fou prend et h6 ont en fait a du mal
à faire peur a du mal à faire g4 g5 là
on va le voir sur la position parce que
j'ai 4 e de bien contrôler et en fait
quand tu joues avec rock tu te retrouves
juste en avec une structure et yves caro
kahn était juste un peu moins bien avec
les blancs pour ce 4 mon avis tu vas
bien mitschek jesus is cette position
exacte dans des arénas contre hammer
exactement celle là et j'ai perdu on n'a
pas du tout changé de fusil d'épaulé de
jouer à fond pour l'attak oui c'est ça
avec grand roque et machin étape en fait
là je considère que c'est juste un peu
moins bien avec les blancs parce que non
et peut-être pas moins bien mais fin en
fait je pensais à toi d'égaliser avec
les blancs ici c'est à toi de jouer
précis pour tenir l'égalité juste autant
diattara bikidik il est nouveau ici il
manque quand ça marche au tableau de
score et pas en fait c'est un match
entre deux joueurs donc maxime vachier
lagrave ces unions en france a et donc
là il a les blancs sont tous lieux
novices et ils jouent contre dominguez
qui avait manqué le meilleur joueur
cubain est en fait ils vont s'affronter
pendant trois heures trois heures et
demie et et voilà et je vous des parties
des jeunes qui finissent à repartir une
autre
et donc si tu marques as tu gagnes tu
marques pointues fait d'une 1/2 et voilà
bien la fin lui qui a plus gagné nos
matches et celui qui est champion reste
champion
voilà du coup et là c'est la troisième
partie est en train de suivre et pour le
moment il ya 1 0 pour le cubain domine
gaz mais comme on le disait avec fable
les cadences vont changer vous fais tu
vas jouer en jouant cinq minutes après
jour en trois minutes plus au client une
minute donc il y aura des trois k danse
différentes et c'est la cadence qui
favorise le plus le joueur cuba donc
même si maxime est plus fort que lui si
on sentira l'égalité à la sortie du 5
puissances se sera sera pas une mauvaise
opération
tout ça et on va pas mal de nouveau dans
le chat est en marche noire qui dit film
de fan de toi ça te connaissez pas les
découvre récemment une cabine joie tch
elle préfère regarder blitz crime à
netflix même pas très intéressant c'est
un jour bitstream sera sur netflix est
aussi un le match le match caruana
caruana carlson à ne pas rater en
novembre fab
je veux qu'on suivra noms suivants
évidemment évidemment on sera là on sera
là mon fab on est toujours là de façon
un tarif on est que la masse est réglé
et la think city cup aussi affable qu'on
suivra oui 11 12 et 13 août
le tout le rapid enfants que le rapide
d'ailleurs que le rapide parce que le
blitz comptait pas quand et pas
commentaire officiel n'a pas les coûts
assez vite ça sert à rien non ça alors
tarabine vient segment dure une heure
alors il y en a 1 d'une heure trente un
d'une heure et en 30 minutes parce que
comme les cadences vont être plus courte
après les parties vont être plus rapide
et pour qui un genre d'excès libre en
termes de nombre de partis
on essaye mans qui découvrent qu'ils
baissent mais où il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont découvert via la vidéo dit
penser d'ailleurs favori fléchissez on
va on va se préparer ça mais on voulait
faire une petite analyse des parties
absolue pensée du coup vu justement ce
sera amusant et pour pas pour aider les
maquis qui je dois dire leur dire un
grand merci ce qu'ils font quand même
beaucoup de choses pour les échecs
il ya beaucoup de gens qui découvrent
les échecs grâce à eux et quelque part
enfin là je vois c'est un peu les stades
ces deux chaises points comme des
nouveaux inscrits tout ça au bas mot
ramener mille personnes sur chaque point
comme et nous 1500 abonnés pour moi ça
prouve que tu vois on n'est pas obligé
de forcer à des gamins dans des écoles à
jouer aux échecs pour les intéressés aux
échecs tu as peut-être que pour
intéresser les gens échec suffit juste
de faire quelque chose de cool ils
viennent par e mail tu vas être obligé
de forcer mec avec un couteau sur la
gorge
oui c'est une c'est obligatoire tu
obligé tu avais peut-être des moyens
plus intéressant dans notre saison c'est
toujours mieux de faire quelque chose
par envie et parce que tu aimes ça joue
est heureux c'est ça bah en fait les
gens qui au footy fin on n'a jamais
forcer quelqu'un à faire du foot c'est
pourtant bien ce que je dis c'est bon du
coup est ce qu'on n'est pas encore moins
bien la femme avec ce pion c4 je ne sais
pas une phase tactique là avec des capes
tout ça et les tacles fonséca longue et
pénible parce que c'est un pion pas ses
protégés après tout les pions sur 104
marge de cet échange tout aura peut-être
du foot bessette et tu mangeras tout le
monde mais oui est-ce qu'on va tout
échanger avec les noirs ils veulent
garder leur d'annoncer sa démission
il contrôle bien des cases d'entrée ni
est de coutume c'est à pousser est-ce
que tu as tu as déjà lui la phrase de
ninkovic le pion pas c'est un dangereux
criminels qu'il faut mettre sous verrous
avec un bloqueur j'ai souvent eu le
coeur devant toi attention un truc un
peu comme ça le récent en fait j'ai pas
est quelqu'un de so foot qui me
il a demandé de décrire un truc pendant
la coupe du monde pour comparer un peu
les échecs qui suit subi stream tout ça
est bien et est en fait je me demandais
de comparer des joueurs avec des pièces
le début je pensais m'être end ap le
flou parce que c'est le sprinteur en
allemand mais finalement je n'en fait
c'est un mélange entre le fou le pop à
ces protéines pures pas assez protégé
métier donc je le surveillais tu
surveilles pub
il est comme mon l'argentine et c'est un
peu ça j'ai peut-être 10 meilleurs -
poétique que nîmes the beach c'est un
peu ont bien peu la même chose même map
et de la position c'est qu'il ya même
bat petra tensions met justement en
prison ainsi fini qu avec boubarak
profil bac vous bakary samb ap alors
voilà c'est mon bail car il se peut être
pour coller à l'actuelle femme mais qui
est se fiancer cas du convent ne sait
plus quoi je vous saurai t je suis
penser à un truc comme ça pendant tes
parties moi j'étais capable quand je
jouais à l'époque de penser à un truc
aussi con pendant que je jouais oui
est-ce que ce pion est plutôt à une ba
paix ou est ce que c'est c'est plutôt
giroud parce que il ne sert à rien repas
d'affaires de giroud ou du pion bas 2 0
ce soir est fort des sudistes du pion tu
ne gagnes pas tu laisses option chypre
où tu es trop méchant pour lui non mais
là en fait même si moi j'en ai voulu
voir le battement pointe pour parler
foot deux jours mais ok vu que la france
a gagné on peut rien dire des champs de
raison descoings finale bat les
vainqueurs ont toujours raison d'être
partout et dans tous les domaines dans
tous les milieux
quand on écrira l'histoire de cette
coupe du monde sur induire giroud c'est
anecdotique
il est champion du monde alors est ce
pont des changes les dames mais il avoue
avec les noix ok ce qu'on dit c'est que
le couple d'amis cavaliers meilleur que
dame fou mais j'ai change va bien qu'on
mette le cas les ans des simples et je
sais pas franchement ça serait que ça se
discute
il est dur à dire mesdames c'est cette
c'est un peu une concession j'aime pas
laisser la dame blanche centralisée
c'est + alt après si tu peux ne pas
changer d'allemand avec la dame à qui il
sera mieux là puisque c'est pas un début
de match de merde là qu'on est en train
de suivre en tout cas c'est clair que
maxime est moins bien là mais je n'aime
pas le scénario enfin j'ai il a fait nul
facile enfin la deuxième il a même un
peu pressé il a gagné la première il a
un peu pressé la deuxième bond en prêt
la finul quand il a voulu et la même si
fait nul il re presque enfin j'en ai
marre labeaume un bon match discuter et
ça donne complètement raison à thiès
points comme avec ces avec ses qualités
chinois mais il ya en fait il va ce sur
quoi c'est le rythme non je rigole hors
jeu sur internet
ouais je sais pas sur tout mais je
voulais dire par rapport au système
qu'ils ont changé on avait été très
critique fin de l'année dernière pour
les joints qui s'étaient qualifiés
oui et j'aime bien reconnaître en fait
que les trucs qui bien que lee qui ont
été faits voilà ils ont mis plutôt que
des gros joueurs et cette année le
système de qualification a permis de
voir l'émergence de ce dominguez qui qui
prouve là en jouant contre maxime qui
avaient tous tous meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux qui fâchent et il n'a pas volé
sa place il la mérite
et pour nous enfin ok on veut que maxime
gagné tous mes côtés ceux ci une
compétition sportive évidemment on est
très heureux d'avoir un adversaire de
valeur hockey maxime qu'un blocus bien
julie maxime leroy noir pourra pas
passer toutes les cases vont être
occupés et il n'y a pas moyen de merenda
l'année droit très nerveux et de la part
de maxime un king nouvelle fois montré
ses aptitudes en finale fab alors il
rejoue la même ligne certes baissé sous
ses 5 îles pour faire baisser ce bien
sûr mais je crois que tu es plus ces
cinq garçons sont à peyrestortes sont
voix répertoire met des six est simple
en face d'eux fait suivre les parties
sont moches pour l'instant bon je suis
pas d'accord avec toi moi je trouve que
c'est des beaux combats technique
positionnait j'aime bien ça joue pas sur
une gaffe quoi c'est pas
alors il a joué faux f5 fab c'est
pourquoi en bouche que la maison je le
connais dans d'autres cas de figure donc
les noirs commencent par par des quatre
cas les pcistes et quatre des six que
ces trois quatre cinq sa série ça et
c'est comme si besoin était qu'elle est
trop étroit faut 2 qui pas censé être un
truc dangereux contre soucier stable
donc j'imagine ce premier jeu alors
est-ce qu'on joue avec b3 four b2 avec
les blancs d'oeuf ou détroit forcément
je concession c'est forcément une
concession faite d'agents fo et de foot
est roi
non en fait c'est sûr qu'avec les blancs
c'est pas ambitieux non mais c'est pas
si mal
en fait il y avait hakobyan et battu
caruana racheter un des états unis
peut-être l'an dernier mais il est clair
que c'est aussi assez malin de jouer
comme ça contre maximy ils se lancent
pas dans des mails et tactiques trop
trop importante
maxime qui peut pas non plus tu vois
aller la fleur au fusil face dominguez
c'était quand même bon dans le petit jeu
tactique aussi médiocre c'est assez
malin ce qui fait dominguez pourra juste
juste jusqu'à maintenant
oui mais voilà je ne sais pas enfin
japon avec juste il donne un pion mais
pour s'activer n'a pas d'eau pas de
réputation
on est con et déjà 700 fabre a cédé du
sang s'écoule vous avez bien partager
tout ça porte ses fruits merci je remets
un petit lien pour partager ouais ça
porte ses fruits merci merci les mecs
c'est ça fait vraiment super plaisir on
est déjà plus que le record du grande
chaise sur cette année quoi premier tour
de speechless kaman puissance eu enfin
ans maxime qui s'activent à fond voilà
il joue dans son esprit grünfeld en fait
il a sans lui donner beaucoup donnent un
pion pour acquis les pièces avec son
sujet ça c'est ce qui fait toute
honorable faible et sa part connaître ce
dont certaines restent indienne ce que
quatre en général c'est vrai que ça peut
donner du jeu cdc pas vaccins bon choix
pratique et en plus il rentre dans son
territoire on disait un dominguez qui et
c'est peut-être un peu de neutraliser
deux
à vouloir trop rentrer les positions
active maxime qui est peut-être le
meilleur joueur annoncé dans ce type de
position aujourd'hui avec n'a qu'à le
brisage donc plus que le top 12
bah oui et non ouais ce qu'on a vu que
top 12 il se vantait 28 cents mille donc
c'est pas très bon vous voyez des
chiffres est lourd de sens c'est
président la fédération afrique
électrique dans un journal il y avait
huit cent mille personnes qui
regardaient en même temps le top-12 donc
on n'arrivera pas n'aura pas eu envie
que ce soit on sera pas à 808 ce soir
malheureusement mais ce chiffre risque
et mesquer génère en fait c'est
d'habitude les chiffres sont pas de quoi
tu vois pas végéter d'habitude ces
genres 50me d'aller peu après la police
deux cent cinquante mille d'après les
manifestants
la c200 d'après la police 800 mille
d'après les manifestants tous par yellow
c'est ce genre cette année la petite
csfa un collège qui est bloquée coiffage
fada 200 collégiens on aimait coup dans
une fac qui ont bloqué un truc et on
nous sommes huit cent mille [ __ ] c'est
le petit moment humour du coup domingues
cas le rendre le pion ouais mais je suis
pas sûr qu'il va le prendre quand tu
peux c'est donc pour ça tu as tout aussi
devecser 5 ou quoi et donc il prend le
pion mais il va faire quoi et b 3 c3 est
de trouver 9 mai mais toi tu vas gigoter
puis tour ces deux machin est fou et 3
es tu vas t'en sortir non la gamme et
qui a aidé dans sa trousse peut même
apprendre à vous mangez auquel il est
mieux là maxime attends tu vas faire
tourner un jeu prêtres des huit acariès
trois échecs sur tours d un parent dont
on attend 1 mettant des japonais
monsieur bah c'est bon en fait qui avait
pas là j'essaie de bouger montrer des
trucs ça c'était pas gagné ça ok ça
avantage c'est sûr ok alors sur tours 8
c'est ce qu' il a vraiment le temps de
faire parce qu'en fait tout sur tout et
on peut prendre prendre et jouer tour
des 3 et là autour b2 et il a pas tant
de faire tour 3 pas sur un mât du
pouvoir
mais surtout réduite qui veut faire
tourner un tour eiffe d1 avec l'idée de
passer en septième as tu sais que ce
ferment qui fait quand même tours 2
ouais mais peut-être il vous fait roi f
oui mais peut-être juste vitesse
cinquième but laurent monte ou en plus
sa structure plus on est très mauvaise
pour les blancs avec le triangle une
tête préfèrent g3 fabergé d'euros f3
cette semaine le roi des cas précédents
après c'est bien mais à qui il va
essayer de pas bouger avec l'élan et de
tenir nul ou passive mais c'est dur à
faire sa fin sur fond bleu
donc et pas mal toit ainsi s'il veut
faire tomber ce histoire des trois être
à deux attaquants sur youtube et donc
peut-être llodra au tour des accords
avec les blancs très axé sur tours d un
an et à tour des six web attendent et
échange mais rien est ce que tu peux
faire tout pour eux un fab donc et
surtout bécistes autres ouais le truc
qui me fait peur c'est tout rêve si
souviens toi et à ta cave de ce que tu
fais f4 ça va être chaud après tu
bougera plus le roi ou angers cooper non
mais il va gagner 5 août ce serait bien
quand même à temps pour prendre un ris
temps p6 wiimote lendemain un est de
s'assurer le tour des six et diac là bas
de robe de gagner avec le roi qu'il faut
désormais qu'un pas mais si le roi blanc
arrive en france et 2 qu'il n'y aura pas
de saison tranquille d'apple quand ben
ouais mais je fait froid et faim la
femme
ouais tour d632 après tu as peut-être
vers des quatre en fait pas vers b4 et
vers des quatre cent des cas je pense
que tu vas pouvoir faire un zoom fable
sûrement il y avait bien sûr continuer
de bien faire il verrait bien rentrer
dans sa zone
mais il est rentré dans le style de
position où il est
ce 10 mai a par contre n'a cas où c'est
un peu le problème mais ça ils se
rendent coup pour coup pour coup quand
on met ensemble et nac est peut-être un
poil plus fort ouais c'est problématique
cette phrase tout re 1 tour 3 je pense
pas que jouer cette finale d'options
femmes la finale deux tours j'ai
vraiment prouvé deux veut mais bon ok
torrent reprendre d'euros ses 5,3 des 3
et 4 ces deux tu as manqué beaucoup de
temps peut être un jour je sais pas
meirieu rb6 roi ses 8,3 bessette et c6
une partie de winch times a voulu en
faire une autre
mais bon hein mais la tour noire peut
pas tenir mes plus vives à jouer c'est
simple ils sont des sorties fab
mais il arrive à l'otan mais très bien
joué de la part de dominguez famin
franchement pour défendre sa contre
maxime qui laisse à tous non mais rend
bien là-bas passive
non mais c'est beau fab par ailleurs tu
vois c est l on te dit les finales où
ils machin à ces cinq ans et peut même
très bien joué aussi des cas pour qui le
seul bloc et canadien j'ai payé des
applaudissements la fin je sais pas
pourquoi je vous laisse mon dos qui
bougeait pas il a besoin ils sont
arrivés coi n'entend pas pu les entendre
ils sont venus il ya du tour des cats
aussi qui va traîner
mais beckham sait bien jouer tu vas
j'aurais pas forcément vu ma b 4 buts
obligé parce que tu sais pas après dix
mois ouais il n'as tu as tu as la perdre
mais auquel j'aurais vu si j'avais une
ou deux minutes mais aussi vite ce que
je me suis fait retour de son copain du
coup fallait pour vraiment faire ces
cinq comme tu l'avais c'est bien une
initiation avec les blancs afin de faire
ça c'est un peu avant de le prendre
mais on peut pas en vouloir aux joueurs
qu la fabia de secondes et peut même
tomber dans ce
il pourrait presque abandonné 1 ouais
bon après ton luth et un petit peu ça
bon assez clément sur la câble euros
actif mais met plus de temps c'est
acquis on égalise
elle tenait bien celui veulent cherche
la turquie va lui rapporter de votre
position il vous l'a même truc qu'on
leur a versé tout le gie maligne que tu
vas continuer sa stratégie si peu de
données du matos pour l'activité a cessé
son style ça a bien fonctionné et ça
peut être la clé du match fade pour pour
maxime parce que dans les positions
techniques dominguez mal après ma
s'affûter même même s'il n'a pas réussi
à défendre la finale précédente dans une
position quand même très difficile où
elle avait énormément de fil à retordre
donc il y avait du film dont il a fallu
le tordre et le rotor encore ouais c
devient très sec après ça c'était très
tendu quoi c'est quand à de l'eau petit
à petit à l'heure j'ai eu une en sata
pas ça tu parles pas quoi non on voit
que tu vas qu'on se dit est-ce que tu tu
plies ton linge le vainqueur que fais-tu
quoi tout arrive que je sois brin de
c'est ce que je suis en train de
comprendre mon falun du coup
c'est pas mal tout ça c'est une petite
pression sur la halle dames l'assurent
de leur corps acta pour les verbes et
sur l'opposition
ouais mais c'est mieux que le système de
londres qu'il a abandonné 1 j'ai
l'impression ouais enfin que de revenir
au dessus plus tard la variante libye
zewski a frappé de nous des cinq
peut-être une tête de park de nos trois
héros pour moi tu vois je me demandais
si on peut jouer b5 à utiliser tout
reprend tout reprend et le pion à sa
sera tabou parce que madame b cet échec
bah c'est justement ce qu'on est en
train de voir et le pion est tabou mais
c'est génial gagné tellement vite placé
le tabou nos tabous à l'expression de la
tueri merci mathieu nous écoutent
bonjour à toi c'est tabou demain
peut-être oui si tu veux et je pense un
bon coup fab l'idée c'est de pouvoir
mais l'attirance t1 et qui mobilise un
peu le cavalier fils alors est ce que on
peut jouer sur d'amin donc tu dois être
j'ai envie de te dire tu as envie de
doubler sur la diagonale si tu me
permets d'expression bon ça parfois
j'utilise cette expression fab laquelle
doublé sur une diagonale
bah ouais on dit plus haut point de
batteries dans son slam alors quelque
part tu tu doubles quoi
je vois dans le chat de pièces comme un
expert une baignoire j'ai dit dany
wrench toc toc trouble is french non non
non
daniel wrench en sueur au front les dix
bas ils ont pensé que maxime et des
supporters du psg aussi mon coeur non
notre ami qui traduit le site en
français était un peu en sueur lui aussi
il m'a écrit kiev et pas supporter de
lyon bat on a le goût il dotera de mieux
elle a traduit lyon lui non non il n'a
pas mis psg en dans la traduction il il
a pas il n'a pas été fidèle au texte au
texte original
du coup le fond cette femme je comprends
pas trop ce fou prend f6 j'ai un son que
maxime fin du régime
mais bon il va devoir comme 2201 roi je
suis ton truc nous lamah cissé bien joué
j'agis penser justement ce damas cissé
vient se glisser pour attaquer parce que
sur dame de tu répètes je pense pas je
pense que tu es un peu mieux assez bien
ce que fait maxime record dans le même
temps l'industrie assez bien joué et fab
c'est bien joué parce que il va le faire
craquer sur trois heures il va pas tenir
dominguez il va pas dire face à la furia
du français le furia lyonnaise cote mais
c'est sidney govou michael essien la fin
de la romieu tout ça parce qu'il était
fort ce milieu de terrain et les siens
monstrueux batllo c'est tellement fin
c'était pas qu'ils auraient pu gagner
que des champions mes chances étaient
plus fortes que paris aujourd'hui c'est
dur à dire non mais pas sur un
championnat dans le sens où hockey
parise ont quand même une armada mégère
dans l'esprit tu sentais qu'il y avait
un homme s'était construit cette des
postes qui avaient juninho faut pas
l'oublier
le rythme des coups francs de partout
moi c'était très bon joueur est ce que
est ce qui peut mettre fin tu vas faire
jean raph 6 bon ça j'allais dire mais
après faire jordan bekaert à 5 à 4
il va sûrement essayer un truc comme ça
que ça s'en faut chercher le contrôle de
son tube ou juste alors maxime kew
gardens la tour ira peut-être des six
est d'amener car ça me paraît pas mal
parce que tu contre attaque le cavalier
sur place tadam
iman cadre avec du retard mais on
apprécie l'effort par an lemon qui nous
dit g4 avec du retard mais on apprécie
l'effort malade tu commences à la paf et
d'amd 4 avant fable par là tu fais d'un
des quatre cas de fois jusqu'à et tu
veux dire que tu ignores tout seul mais
je n'y peux rien mais sûre qu'elle
décide je te fais du dam b2 d'un machin
comme ça et du coup je vous dis ok dams
et sa tour 17 cheveux très électorat
fuite et je fais ma vie après m mais il
a fait tomber quatre moins bons mais
peut-être f 3,3 c'est le coquen je pense
et ouais ce que le cavaliere 4 bien
placé l'empêchent dames enfin les
montées se faire flasher cap d'amore des
fois je 4g le pas mal d'idées
mais ce n'est pas un excès d'humilité ça
me fâche 4 me paraît très bien
non mais juste en fait tu bouges pas
trop donc le canard c'est juste la tvh
e-doceo blanc enfin c'est pas cette fois
jusqu'à 3h 3 mai au même temps des
quatre où il faut faire flouer 6 fab tu
acceptes de te moquer il écoute le
stream coincé on a compris c'est yann à
petit il ya le petit délai et que ici
dit il que faire je ne sais plus fait
rire les visages skiset bishop et fort
alors je crois et maxime aussi kevin
bord 10 tonnes
vous g5 ok je ne suis je sais trop
grillé si je vous fais je ne peux pas au
ton suivre les cours ok avec cavaliers
des six vrai mais bon qu'est des six
mois tu as ton utilisé ce qu'on veut
faire dames 1
et avec outre menacé d'un f un échec
avec des perpète
il est toujours demeuré 2% m/m et du oui
c'est ça dames 1 dames 1 prise en effet
si adam f1 il ya au moins perpète voit
plus ce n'est plus je vois pas mais en
fait tu vois pas d'autres coûts que
damian fab d'autres h5 wallace menace
m'attendais quand même le bon bout le
prendre sûrement rouffach le cap peut
être humain
vivendi vende ou fake f4 comprendre on
apprend avec cinq échecs
hier à pranger 5e je pense qu'il ya plus
rien milliards par la queue voilà c'est
à partir de 20 h 30 à 6 femmes cette
partie il ya même fou e7 qui est
possible ici femme complètement
inattendu d'ailleurs tu défends cette
même peut-être qui a valu aux quatre le
retour est ce que c'est ouais mais du
coup puis on prend g4 et f5 échec peut
arriver tu peux reprendre b5 amener du
coup tu veux pas me fier de l'ennemi
contre attaquer le roi ouais parce que
lecavalier le dangereux criminel fawcett
je pensais très bien joué mais va-t-il
devoir quoi ça me paraît être un coup
quand même écoute il le stream quoi
c'est un peu mais fois ça c'est
peut-être
pour oum tempo quoi et du coup je
pensais bien pour maxime
je crois qu'il veut le matin je sais pas
fabuleux pagaie mathéou prendre le fruit
de quatre foyers encore des échecs et
encore dames 1
mayroy ch 5 g 6 échecs et d'amener un
jeu pas être des échecs mais j'insiste
c'est t'y prendre à g4 après vote
surgissent tu prends un cul ture par
dame nature vieux rêve 5 t à prendre et
peut prendre g46 non mais avec quatre
ans plus tard jeudi 05 août avocat a été
avec quatre fantastiques l'orangé 6
comme le roi de sortie mais il réfléchit
me fait peur parce que le cas de ce
patient direct bref et le beau jeu je
sais pas ce que c'est que ce coup là il
a raté fawcett enfin bon on va dire que
vous c'est nous prendre en otage et du
coup d'une gaze change il vendra l'âge
d'or ce moment là je pense une très
mauvaise idée l'école se défoncer c'est
horrible encore qui joue une ligne ça va
je peux contrôler le destin qui sait pas
trop violent
maxime dans la neige d'or postaux après
tu es tu veux faire plaisent non bien
sûr mais là encore on trouve sur place
enfin les trois deux un match quatuor
français en compétition
j'ai envie de te dire je commence à bien
sentir ce match dominguez l'aller
salah sea life us est à mon avis la
perdez pas un mois qu'on a raté un truc
bien sûr ça va être un beau coup faut se
tasse avec dur pour dominguez ça fait
dur pour le public cubain petit pan
sahel
ils sont sur la tête haute en sueur
qu'après france belgique pour les belges
fab à la fin du match
petite pensée aux francophones aux
belges prennent effet pas empêché femmes
on est méchant ce possible
ouais mais bon là il menace fait pour la
carte ou d'un prof web sont dans les
deux cas ces crs parquet prend le cadam
prend 9 51 c'est cet échec et c'est
cette c'est pas maintenant j'ai pas au
québec 425 prélogie remy va faire
défoncer la non da fait je vais pas trop
ce que tu attaques et clément est bon
avec les nerfs très bon un peu de mal à
finir développement allaient là les
droits by side est en train de baisser
la tête de wingen assez petit bard
encore mais génial comme à chaque match
c'est pareil il va s'enfoncer sur son
siège et je suis resté plus que ses
lunettes quoi dégage jeu il y en a plus
[Rires]
pire
affable on l'a insupportable c'est
horrible car à disparaître
profitez bien de dominguez les mecs dans
deux heures on le voit plus un chaque
match au speech à 5 c'est pas le mec qui
finit par faire petit à petit budget
s'enfonce trop sur la corde
il a relevé la tête quand il a relevé la
tête j'ai ici si la foule l'a soufflé
quoi ben je sais pas mais qui m'a vu
qu'il ordonne g5 wallace et coiffure je
me tais toi je suis quand même
kerry king s'est réduit de ce projet
franchement je serais plus elle est bien
c'était sur karl scène et et surtout se
refuse à une norme c'est fantastique ce
qu'il sait de plus détecter g8 c'est moi
qui t'ai limite moi à merde qu'est g8
double échec amer de la merde il est
complètement relevé sur le siège la c4
dans les séries quand on revoit sa main
on revoit son menton il est de partout
quoi bon accueil aux fermes et la wii
vont mais attend qu'elle est
complètement fermé non d'accueillir
faire mais bon après il ya en plus des
trois toujours mais là c'est vraiment
maxime donne un truc exprès pour une
compensation long terme c'est génial ça
tu vas faire rager 7 machin et puis
c'est juste fantastique avec et ses
trois échecs dames à 4 ok ça peut
marcher encore mais bon j'ai pas pu me
fous des 3 après tout on nous dit dans
le chat que le mieux était gousseïnov
avec vous ses noces était tellement
fantastique femme dans un petit refuge
et de spebio
et ces trois dom français 3
nous sommes étrangers deux de ses sept
des neuf c'était dur pour lui car le sel
pendant deux petites finales technique
60 couche est parti et où est mon égal
puis tu es de finale à chaque coup tu
perds un micro au micro piaf un ami l'a
ratée maximin c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'il
a raté sa et le wafou g2 c'était peut
être un g2 et g3 donne concept ou écoute
on va pas se plaindre un fab non mais
vous des 3 et l'on pense et c'est
logique tu sors le fou tu défends la
tourache un oignon détour il attaque le
cavalier aucun
quant à celles qui nous disent ils
gagnent ça là le match est gagné
psychologiquement mais possible elle en
fait des cinq peut-être se passer mais
je pense pas du tout que ce soit fini
fable
et ces trois livres quand même mais bon
je pensais que ça marchait pas toujours
des siens pour le point de quasiment au
cas où qu'aimes tu récupères tapiès de
toute façon oui et quand tu fais dan
ceinture par le quadrillage si ceux-ci
fable mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils soient
moins bien en fait cette fois 4 ici à
epinay sur des cinq de fer prise prises
des 5 et d'un programme double ouais
mais bon vu que c'est peut-être juste
dame b6 fait échanges les dames
écoute c'est bon signe pour le moment
puisque je domine je devine beaucoup de
coups de dominguez et comme dirait
blague c'est plutôt mauvais signe pour
lui quoi te dire que tu joue très mal
pas ou que lui donc c'est plutôt bon
signe même le peu mal partie non après
beaucoup de chance sa femme parce qu'il
n'avait pas vu la double attaque et
même et tourcoing f6 et ça va en fait
matériellement ça a donné quoi cette
égalité matérielle a pris apprend à
prendre comme free ok le problème c'est
la tourache 6 clairement mallard en
france joue pas trop mais bon déjà pas
plus ou moins il a pas mal géré quand
même de 1000 magasins parce que tu vas
contre maxime genre de position ont de
quoi bon demander deux chiens qu'il ya
peut-être deux ou trois de nouvelles
attaques des six bons conseils de ses
copains parce que l'entourage tisse
aussi moody's a et fou prend b3 et tout
ça marchera par ailleurs à la dame qui
reviendront dès de couvrir mais le truc
c'est que sur recettes aya puis on prend
1,5
va falloir défendre une finale mais
attend et ce que je peux faire recette
qui on prend aux cinq qui ont quant à
eux cinq dames prend 1,6 vous prend b3
tu vois mon miroir g7
il va prendre des systèmes marge de
cette finale mon femmes on la tient ou
pas mais qui est complètement perdante
mans
mais hockey maxime que peut-être nous
faire de la magie chez pas naïve essayer
de jouer vite la pression autant je suis
je conseille de morta ce jeu vite et
bien le fou j'ai 4
quand je regarde les calmes non mais là
il simple relevé sur son fauteuil
enfin babel tours 1 mais bon il va faire
trois tours à froid ils vont tenter des
trucs tout ça pour age 2 c'est parce que
sa tête avait quatre des cinq femmes là
non je n'ai pas envie il veut éviter le
contre jeu il essaie de défendre ses
pions métier qu'ils avaient été très
très bon contre meilleur en finale ce
qui est meilleur c'est un client et il
avait été très très très bon dans ces
finales t'écris contre meilleur hockey
c'est pas le même niveau et quand même
tu as meyers et son point fort à ses
poses avec à tour la tour pour celui de
tawke et nous te prendre le football
ouais mais bon oui mais sur ce une bonne
chose pour le monde
sèchement s'il va revenir en d4 est
double tour non mais en blitz être bon
dans ces finales technique ces deux
trois mois je prendrais je suis roi b3
j'ignorais les pions et je pousserai
mettions pas scellier personnes c'est
des fois pour gagner il faut donner il
faut ce soir des pneus bien plat seul
coup plus roanne je laisse les pions de
façon c'est des pions qui sont faites
moi j'appelle ça des cafards en fait pas
si tu viens était pieds tu che survie
des petites carottes non mais c'est
propre ainsi la nature en finale le
héros est souvent les bons buteurs sont
bons en finale je préfère marquer ouais
j'avais surtout rashka tu vas faire
croît c3 vrai nom il revient il ya du
temps mais le développeur qui lie les
deux temps déjà fait aussi bizarre on
veut peu pour se
ah oui à b6 bessette est tombé deux
propos pour qu'est ce que c'est bien
joué tour en ckd bessette et maintenant
le roi 2 permet surtout bekaert de faire
pour des demeurés 14h17 de contrôler le
coton ouais mais ça fonctionne pas sa
femme là le roi court très vite on sait
que le roi blanc et va bien avant le bon
réflexe doit mémoire on l'a vu au stage
voilà je quatre prix ça fait ouinch heyy
d'abord et maintenant il va faire tour à
sept tours un entourage sacré entourage
cette l'armée
mais je m attends il en train de se
planter
ah non ça tient djezzy il va faire bref
trois pattes mais non ok l'égalisation
alors la longueur et au bout de la
partie mais pas faire comme nouvelle
tentative de nuire aux gens pour un vrai
grand vide à la semi teint hâlé coupe
des quatre nations
quand je ne sais pas le même niveau
dominguez est meilleur c'est qui le plus
fort et domine gaza même si meilleur est
très fort 2002 encore au dessus un nom
mais dominguez parmi ces joueurs pas
très connu tu vois du grand public ce
qu'il est vraiment pas connu du grand
public c'est un de ceux qui peut tenir
contre les meilleurs joueurs du monde en
blitz
mais bon je vais me re répéter mais le
mec était champion 2 bis
enfin ça veut dire quelque chose c'est
un excellent blitzer et il est peut-être
très motivé pour ce match parce que
comme il joue plus vraiment eu à l'appui
sa carrière ou quoi que je veux dire
mais il est cependant ou quoi peut-être
pour lui c'est un gros tournoi en fait
sa ba moment il peut briller quoi
brouiller encore de l'adrénaline je veux
ça la cheville je tombe amoureux de ce
cube heures et brûle brûle ses manies
site officiel aucun des deux joueurs de
prendre à 27 et demi à deux ans et demi
pourquoi ce qui est des plus sévères
2007-2008 où 2011 2011
ouais on puisse un tournoi que vlad
jouer puisqu'il a été champion du monde
alma ata
alors cette pollution mon avis pas mal
pendant les candidats proclamé ci mais
ça compte pour le classement elo bain
pour le classement de chaises comme
alors pour le moment les classements sur
internet peut encore très importante
mais pas vu le nombre de gens qui
suivent ces tournois par rapport au
tournant réel là je sais pas faut
arrêter de penser que le vélo c'est
important les titres c'est peut-être
plus important que les lots au final il
était champion du monde en 2008
par ailleurs si tu gagnes le speech s je
pense que c'est une compétition qui dans
l'avenir sera importante parce que ce
qui donne de l'importance aux
compétitions fap ccc le public qui les
suit plus et suivi plus et les fatwas
donc c'est un grand match on n'hésitait
pas à une nouvelle fois un jeu redit
mais nous tous un peu ce même problème
même moi le monde de toute faute de
mettre trop d'importance à ce vélo
peut-on s'en fout c'est un truc à un
moment tu es c'est de la merde en fait
donc fait je sais pas la fin de ta vie
tu vas pas dire où j'ai été les low
boots était petit bah oui par exemple la
ddt
il était champion d'europe tu ailles
pourra toujours dire j'ai été champion
d'europe
bader c est le titre qui met en avant il
y pas j'ai été deux mille six cent
soixante dix en fait quand il rencontre
des gens lambda dans la rue il dit bah
j'ai été champion d'europe d'échecs tu
as toi qu'est ce que tu as gagné et les
titres c'est sur pareille gères tu peux
avoir gagné le pari grandes chaînes
sourds ou quoi enfin ça parlera jamais à
personne le parent est grande chez
source
oui enfin 8ième je suis champion
d'europe 28 c g simple il faut se disent
donc je pense que c'est une bonne idée
que ça tu as un clochard qui nous dit ça
joue vraiment bien des deux côtés ça
fait plaisir et c'est un gros match
suite pour l'église c'est un titre
quelconque d'avoir un vélo mais en fait
on regarde un joueur de tennis c'est
pareil je lui demande pas son classement
en fait tu as i lay et des grands
chelems et toi qui l'a gagné et ou quoi
ou son classement mondial après mais tu
vas pas dire j'étais cassé 15 de tueur
on s'en fout en fait je pleure c'est un
fou prosys un jour en janvier g5 dessus
la tête pour ces deux échecs aussi
femmes mais bon ça peu rodé mais jean
pierre raffarin gafou siècle et blanc de
la majorité van dam des noirs qui dit
peu avant c'est un jour qui peut courir
va quand on parle des dangereux
criminels mais je crois qu'il faut le
mettre sous verrous que dégage le prends
ton psion je l'enlève de l'échiquier en
plus dangereux criminels
mais peut-être qu'ils avaient des trois
quilles et c5
mais oui par qui et 17 mai fut accueilli
des trois j'aime bien ses fins et ont
qu'à rallier ça aussi femmes
non mais bon enfin juste pour résumer le
truc sur les lots après un très haut
niveau c'est important pour aussi pour
lesquels il faut les candidats pour les
habitations et les tournants ja je
parlais plus tôt pour rouge ne faut pas
se focaliser là dessus du tout et aussi
c'est un truc que je trouve vraiment
stupide c'est en 2002 et en fait je sais
l'argument et 2000 mais ça peut compter
au classement fit son jeu trois parties
par jour et justement ça chauffe à cet
accomplissement du nord cadeau à
l'époque c'est très bien a tant fait
pour lui si ça a marché la bce
mais bon il va faire quelques huîtres
mais bon même tu dois faire face à face
à la turquie forte en finale à moins
qu'ils étendent de placer à 4 maintenant
mais non ça va pas suffire
on accable oui ce que j'ai dit c'est pas
suffire c'est de la merde
non mais en fait j'ai pas je n'aime pas
le fait que des sites actifs pour rodez
et on voit si tu attends c'est ça tout
le temps mais elle pense qu'il ya plus
pour ces deux motards je redoute fera à
bord des trois tacles à tous
il y aura plus g5 parce qu'elle est
blanche le g5 d'une chute eu à faire
cavalier le 8 mai la finale lb torride
les pièces mineurs vont se faire dominer
par un vote qui doit tenter fou consiste
or ces deux camps même voix des trois
étoiles b2
tout comme ça parce que le fou à part à
défendre à dos ou des 3/4 je pense est
faux dessins que tu les changes qui
prend 1,2 tu feras moins bien quand même
mérité peut-être c'est l'autre option et
je préfère celle là en fait à prendre
sus l'apprendre réussissant que les
caisses mineures elles vont être
éteintes par les par la majorité pour
nos enfants on a des gars c'est partout
et la tourte très fort au final peut
lutter contre de petites beaucoup plus
comme the villain
parce qu'il ya d'autres options du genre
tour 7 mn entoure cette sert à rien je
pense tour ces deux tours b2 et autour
h21 tour quelque part pensé même âge de
en fait perso pour éviter les rois c3
les trucs comme ça et ça change rien
c'est la même idée
tu peux aussi peut-être joué à quatre
juste maintenant direct pour ce point
donc et c'est quoi ton ce sera naissent
way d'autres c'est un peu la même idée
pour s'en moquer food et 5 il faut quand
même
mais ce que pas faire flouer à 6 du coût
et te dire que ton fout en fait ils te
prends les cases du cavalier qu'il est
mal placée devant les pions ce que tu as
du mal à pousser d'abord quoi qu'il
arrive il est pas trop prévu faut aussi
s'il s'en sort c'est un peu chanceux
mais puisqu'il ya fifa de notre
gastronomie nation de foot mais en fait
tu vas là je pars d'impliquer le fesman
de calcul ou tweets on soit induit très
bien enfin au début c'est que fait de se
focaliser là dessus
non mais car que 6,4 points 8 sur les
fédérations les machins les trucs la
fidh et vont se gargariser du truc qu'on
s'en fout en fait ça change pas
exception à des chèques et des recettes
qui les regardent
oui mais je sais que j'arrive à venir
ici où ils trouveront d'ailleurs a pas
des lots réinventer le système mais qui
avait été refusée par le tennis
d'ailleurs le discours mais enfin c'est
juste le lot j'aime bien me le tennis ce
n'est pas un mais c'est juste mais tu
devrais avoir un malus de points quand
tu joues pas oui tu dois tu perds des
points constitue peuvent le temps et
d'autres fois c'est ici alors l x 6 mais
c'est intéressant parce que la casse des
cinq en fait il ya trois pièces qui
veulent être dessus et y en a qu'une qui
peut y être
j'aime bien cette idée de te dire pour
posséder pions et tu vas avoir besoin de
dégager des pièces alors peut-être faut
faire re série
mon bep cap maillard wade de du coup ça
va permettre de ramener le fou 1,47
histoire ou au fait des dégâts de le
faire une fois ci sont confiants mais
catherine après qu un bon mais c'est
bien pour maxime non mais pk tu dois il
ya le temps aussi invoqué 6,7 en premier
ceux qui parient grand chose à faire
jousse tendrement écoute c'est pas si
idiot dans la mâture aussi pour ces deux
blocs un peu mais même peut-être foot
est roi
enfin quand même fait des quatre
intermédiaires m'ont donnés pour éviter
ça mais bon il de faire tour à trop
ensuite tous à son écoute c'est très
bien joué de la part des noirs faut
admettre que même si fou pour cent à mon
avis ce qu'il peut faire c'est tour à 3
de faire tourner je pense doubler cette
tâche aux jeunes des cinq mois je prends
un f3 je reviens en dessous et si je
prends h7 là tu es fou 17,4 ff7 ou fuzer
cave
non mais c'est super bien joué parce
qu'en fait le deux contre cinq et il est
un peu bloquée mais bon parler un jour
femmes pour 3,1 et 3,3 tour à tour c'est
vrai mais c'est super bien défendu on va
prendre à deux femmes va faire foudroyer
prix ce qui peut te dire direct je
pensais que vous faire [ __ ] entoure
ces de rien qu'est ce que cous
mais brett irak peux tu as tu nous as
troyak fait pousser 4 mais bon on est
timide est aussi un fait cette affaire
fou dessin quand même pour échanger les
fous arrêter le pion avec ton roi est
joué pour deux contre zéro mais le truc
c'est que les pions blancs ils sont
reçus d'être de faire tourner ses sept
tours à cette fable à tour ses huit
courageux
mais tant mieux jouer oui sur ces 8 de
son budget et sa base arrière pour un 17
août chez pomme tomber sa team detroit
mais les fonds sont bloqués et tu vas
faire être 4,3 machin et d'orange le cas
au temps frais ça va gagner un ami a
essayé de faire rager 63.7 maintenant
commander 6 3 8
non on ne parle pas à temps hi fi ça il
peut faire oui pouvait autant prêt sympa
femmes minces et bourg sérieux femme
quand les échecs ses jeux comme ça c'est
pas nous parti de merde et l'ont bien il
va revient en v8 mais c'est nul je pense
trois poids poids fable quel niveau de
jeu fable dans cette partie elle s'en
soit pas décidé à lâcher ses coups
non mais attends tenir maxime en finale
comme ça c'est fort le level qu'on a
dans ce match c'est du très très très
très haut niveau fab
donc c'est bizarre qu'il a peut-être
envie je n'ai pas du tout sur l'audition
des six bizarre même sinon pour les
parties de malades et tu vois
l'algorithme a comme d'hab ils seront
pas aidés léger avantage à dominguez
sait peut-être dominguez qui domine ce
très légèrement je sais plus le nom
ouais mais c'est lui qui a manqué
l'occasion en randonnée qui c'est qui a
raté le fawcett s'est plutôt dominguez
qui a raté l'occasion dominguez qui a
plus de vies qu'un chat un chat cubain
un puma on à faire un puma ici femmes
ont par endroits les plus minces mais
mais ils sont souvent aussi son pouvoir
par coup attention ils peuvent se faire
c'est vrai que les cubes en finale tu as
eu tu as eu la carte blanche qui était
aussi l'axé jour du final un toit c'est
ce qui me rend peut-être un peu à notre
école française quand même un final
ouais je sais pas maxime il est pas mal
non mais c'est pas à l'école française
maman n'a pas d'école française
je sais juste à l'école française des
échecs en sueur quoi mais il ya encore
peu je n'aime pas l'ombre d'une école
non mais les joueurs français c'est
plutôt de la remarque la culture
française talibane au tac tic
embrouilleur dur à battre
accrocheurs après lumière prend sa part
si tu parles maximou etienne calé final
ils sont la mesure même un peu maso il
pas mal parce qu'il a eu il a eu
beaucoup de quoi espérer de neuf donc tu
es un homme venu assurer que le ruf rgt
n'état pas d'écoles françaises
ouais t'as pas l'école française des
échecs
voyage 3 août en main pour travailler
depuis 80 ans là c'est pas mal ce trait
maxime des coûts
mais coûte rien il est pas mal notre
petit maxime là sur leur devenir a
oscillé tranquille jusqu'à maintenant
d'autres entrées dans le bar mais aussi
l'autre il a gagné mais c'est plus sur
la gamme g 6 vous allez me dire que ben
et le match et non fabien tu peux perdre
la lucidité un nom mais peut-être qu'il
aimait vraiment plus finalement
il a une idée en tête en jenson d438
maxime jeune rentre jamais dans les
variantes ebooks
c'est un peu déprimant là ce qu'ils
faisaient en écoute ci s'il reconnaît
initiative mais ça c'est pas mal fois je
tranche un genre pression de façon
franchement efficacement pour jouer sur
les cases mange son ca va coupler nord
garde un bon dynamisme dans l'opposition
bon pour l'instant c'est bien parce
qu'en fait il joue à lille joue au bon
tempo près le b 4 parce que des paquets
et c3 il n'y a pas qu'à relief 4 ne fut
ni box des quatre sympa franchement s'il
faut qu'il dégage cet ouvrage 3
confiance a juste fait retour à agen où
je suis un subtil courage de en disant
où je vais faire 4 1 jour mais bon ça
c'est un peu trop profond dans sa maxime
chirac etc et juste autant très bon le
soir maxime de villentrois plus en plus
à même la même à cette clé dans soir
mais les bonnes à rien est-ce qu'on fait
d'amis j'ai cinq policiers furieux qui
tombe
non je demandais branchement shq et font
des six mosquées de fourchette attaque
g5 ce que je pense que l'intérêt des
chambres à échanger les dames avec les
blancs et peut-être et ses doigts cette
colonne h pour un choeur activer la tour
d'être inclure j'ai un match on peut
faire tourner autour d'un jeu qu il
valait mieux marquer le 4 août il
s'était entouré c'est un triste
yasar défoncé
il va remplacer lequel quatre pieds
cette fois ça recommence le problème
c'est qu'il peut pas oublier ce qu'on
peut sac et une kalach tu vois où un
truc à un moment donné mais non mais non
c'est fini
du coup marc antoine bouillon h 2 après
pas sûr que j'ai changé grand-chose ans
est parti baath ce bateau gaza tour aux
quais du cap bon fromage 5e se faire
matraquer régime honni que faire cailler
prend sbb troaré pour défendre
voilà une fin pour preuve de maximum
d'une hausse tourcoing de 2 d'ici peu
n'importe quoi mais qui était trop
petite paroisse et de calcul etc et
s'éprend les droits l'oit umass
cavaliers f6 aussi pour couper la
connexion damaddar au carré de mangani
moitié doit tacticien mais vous c'est
trop dur je pense quand même mais
peut-être qu'un lycéen tu dois quand
même mais voyez bien que dams et si vous
jouez votre défense
mais ya pas de défenseur bon maintenant
reprendre qu'en montant point de gagné
une pièce parce que ça gagnera une pièce
pour prendre 2 3 e quai ces trois serres
fedom c6 marseille mobilise au cavalier
garnier menace la main de l'étranger 3
et peut-être d'alger site un test que tu
peu d'hommes j'ai six toros de tourcoing
le dock et c3 mange mange froid c'est un
tour bien être les rois on va juste le
talent il a quand même je suis
d'amérique avec la même idée non damée
ces chèques dans le système machin qui
ont vu les d4 un jeu c'est tiré par les
cheveux mais il défend bien mais le truc
c'est que je suis inquiet pour moi je
suis inquiet je suis très heureux mais
je suis je suis inquiet pour le cubain
en 3 + 1ère 1 + 1 parce que maxime il a
tellement davantage la pendule à chaque
fois et je vais maintenant on a vu des
joueurs accès janvier truck driver grid
succès c'est un animal quoi elle tape
des 5 lui évite les dames aussi saoulé
merchin bizarre je suis reprotage son
cavalier et elle crée les quais des
quatre le machin un retour salué ce
document ce prénom ici j'imagine pas été
très bons problèmes avec son grand bain
& click et c3 des machins ok sur dame
ces deux tours c'est peut-être tout
reproche
est 3e avec dame france et 8 et donc des
cinq monstres mais voilà oui souffre aux
graves inquiétants franchement six ans
soir dans ces deux là c'est fou c'est de
faire h5 juste en voiture son audace
rien on n'a pas fait une menace aux
normes qui condamne france et voilà les
faits recueillis détroit je sais pas
mais bon ça défend bien quand même un
fap passe quand une position comme ça
alors voici le niveau de confiance
non mais maxime va pas se porter vers
toi ou moi un peu assez bien ce qu'il
fait je vais jouer sur mac du couloir
finito puisqu'ils sont forts en tacty
femmes
la réunion se serait planté quoi c'est
sûr tous eu quatre poteaux alors c'est
la première fois qu'on mène dans ce
match là bas et c'est peut-être là d'un
parti de 5 + 1 parce qu'il ya 7000 30 au
chrono donc suivant combien de temps
elle dure et les parties on était assez
longue jusqu'à maintenant ça pourrait
être la dernière dans cette cadence
femme je passe on espère ou pas mais et
c'est une bonne nouvelle je disais tout
à l'heure que si on si on tournait à
égalité en cinq prix sens très bien et
on peut tourner à puissant voire même
plus de 1 la soupe au lait
anatole kg 81 points c'est aussi ça
ressemble à un parti qu'on a réalisé ce
matin font à cette partie navarra très
bonne vidéo femmes à mieux voir
il veut quoi le pendre des cas de faire
des soins peut-être le bon sens peut se
dégager
je pense prise prisé des sacs à main ces
thématiques non sur pause et kate double
à reprendre d'options
soit tu as soon as tu peux accepter ton
tueuse reste sur notre faim j'ai cinq
pays hôte
pas je sais pas je trouve ça bizarre ce
qu'a fait dominique domarchi et viola tu
menaces même juste bêtement qui ont
produit cinq d'aller prendre v6 coach
larry tu dois prendre et faire des cinq
intelligent puisque tu veux faire
d'autre
ok mais à infléchir chaque et j'ai
quatre chefs dont 27 kg 4 possible aussi
mais bon tu fais ou g5 ne peu débile le
kg qu'à nîmes 15e vers les monstres dans
cette italienne a essaimé partout mais
c'est des endroits les plus monstrueux
qu'à d'autres bons soient ils sont à ne
pas garder ça simple en fait il ya
maintenant des cinq peut-être maintenant
une époque beaucoup
arias en offrant le monde ira du quai
l'épreuve 2007
les courageux de rentrer dans ses
appareils en temps
même sous forme
je n'ai pas gagné à ses rêves non j'ai
peut-être craquer physiquement
ce que je vois pas de prime de match du
couloir il y aura toujours un pour venir
couvrir pour les éléments non je pense
qu'il vient de rater une version
écoutent ils auraient quand même pu
faire le fric avec des 5 1 ça n'a pas
l'air d'être si grave
non mais surprise des capteurs prendre
une pièce où celle-ci des options
lorsque vous prend vous prend qu'il
allait prendre écoute on va pas ban a
assisté sur son service il peut la
perdre on prend je vois pas trop de
bonnes défenses coûté 120 avec un bond
de 28% des villes peut-être qu'à voyager
baye cheikh intermédiaires n'ont soit
pas mieux que la shdm l'intérieur ça me
paraissait quand même pour pour doubler
les pions c'est pareil comme le b à ba
non mes toiles je ne sais pas mais
peut-être donné entendre plus souvent de
quelle idée de ce que c'était si la
famille du pou y avait une pio et je
crois qu'il faut être en prise aussi
quoi ouais enfin au début c'est kg 5e 8
lier la main d'henry lors étant prises
non mais là c'est écrasant mais bon ok
l'adjointe bruxelles et défendre des
finales de leur mère fois encore la
gagner un
même en juste surpris qu'il n'ait pas
fait cas je crois non potable annonce
aux basses à ce que les élèves ont cours
sur deux trois fois f5 j'imagine qu'en
même temps des 4
il est malin oui ben ils menacent de
faire tout raté un nom qu'on doublé tour
sur la colonne des ampoules qui avait
bien et sur ses 6 et 4 donc retrouver
votre kéké dans son volet idée simple je
fais c'est 5 à sf4 et essaye de gigoter
ouais on va passer cinq grosses
concessions sur les caisses des six ne
peut-être tétons n'est plus là en feutre
c'est ce genre de considérations une
sorte de all in mais bon quand vient le
tour des deux kiev 4 tourne mais tu peux
faire du prix ce qui est vraiment à rien
et tu as si le pion étaient en âge 3 me
voilà à terme h 4 sûrement du coup pas
et peut-être c'est moins grave entre
guillemets
et c'est qu'à regarder si c'est oui tu
protèges mais deux noms mais le niveau
de jeu un peu baissé de côté dominguez
et tu vois c'est un peu comme les matchs
de rafa nadal
mais bon ok je sais pas il n'a pas
encore perdu
il me faire créer trois contrôles sains
et les revend même s'ils vont tellement
une bonne tête à queue est ce que tu
peux faire des six qu'elle prend pour
être prises en b 6 bayer procès 5 et
chaque département tu peux pas dire
koléa qui avait dit sèchement complète
faut quand même faire que tu feras f7
par là bas tu fait tomber deux buts
encaissés 4 après tu fait recaler des
trois échecs mais malgré tous les pions
majeurs la main en direct mais va tenter
un bâtiment doit programme je crois que
ça va peut-être prendre ici su faire qui
est des trois échecs et tours b 8 je
peux cavale et calais qui a aidé trois
intermédiaires et effet retour des 8es
le cavalier b6 et et en finn est ok ça
c'est une bande au team
enfin l'om de dominguez séparément son
niveau de jeu ce qu'il est trop lent et
là y'a pas fou c'est 2000 à plus très
souvent autour des systèmes toujours
mais oui
ce
non mes cuisses grande donne aucune
chance non mais on va dire que van il
prend du temps parce qu'il est moins
fort mais hier son problème c'est pas
vraiment ça tu as même laïque le pion de
man il s'est bien battu mais il met trop
de temps quand il est trop lent pour des
six portes quoi est il simple t3f 4 ici
bas malgré tout assuré que maxime a
toujours dominé de main ça dépend d'où
le plein tarif 4 maintenant du coin
demain
corps des deux femmes il ya touré fin
aussi sec à venir des 4 je pense je le
garde sur le coût de l'échec
à l'adoption passée les
non mais t'es lieu 3 tranquille et à
surtour des cas tu fais roger trois
échecs étaient français de fou fini qui
représente 3 + 1 c'est ça ouais touitou
selon une mini pause enfin on peut te
laisser tourner tout mais je pars bordé
oui tu reviens tu as une petite pause
aussi du coup c'est nouvelle pause et
maxime fait une paye plus qu'à le
maillot de l'olympique lyonnais
mars je me suis trompé de micros désolé
les mecs j'avais j'avais pu déboucher le
mauvais micro donc je disais que ray
c'est bien ce que ce qu'a fait maxime
juste ici il tourne
il tourne à plus 2 donc c'est très bonne
nouvelle et il va falloir t'y qui
continue comme ça et si tourne à plus 4
avant les buts +5 par nelly ce sera
suffisant donc si regagne le match de
troyes precinct avec on va dire deux
points d'écart ça devrait aller jusqu'au
bout après s'il tourne à plus 2 il
faudra quand même se méfier puisque en
plus un os bien vu les surprises dans
des matchs de ce pitch est ce surtout la
toute première saison c'est les gemmes
les battles championship et les
deathmatch y avait déjà eu des surprises
donc il faudra toujours se méfiant un
plus un ça peut être une cadence un peu
un peu spéciale après trois heures de
jeu est physique qui rentre en compte
mais ok s'ils continuent comme ça là et
que il continue à mettre la pression la
dynamique du match quand même très
positives donc bon c'est très bien après
en sport il faut il faut toujours
toujours toujours se méfier
et là c'est pas comme dans d'autres
matches qu'on a vu cette saison il y
avait déjà quatre cinq six points
d'écart avec un match qui était
complètement à sens unique
là c'est pas à sens unique dominguez qui
a quand même assez bien joué les parties
elle se joue pas à grand-chose il défend
bien non après 2015 il ya un vrai
problème avec les blancs aux siens parce
que des cats à lui a pas trop convenue
ça lui a pas plu il est parti sur catena
genre s'est très mal passé pour
dominguez donc de quel côté va-t-il
aller vers quoi va-t-il partir je sais
pas quoi mais avoir après un avoir
et n'oubliez pas si vous souhaitez voir
plus de vidéos des chèques faut aussi
aller sur la chaîne youtube si vous
voulez voir plus de de contenu après
après les matchs etc
je mets le petit lien vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne youtube ya déjà plus
de 750 vidéo sur la chaîne donc si vous
voulez vous êtes intéressé plus
largement par les échecs vous pouvez
toujours filé sur la chaîne youtube et
mardi soir sur cette même chaîne à
partir de 19 heures il y aura le match
great uk contre
nepomniachi donc il sera encore un gros
choc et il y aura pas mal de stress pour
nous aussi puisque ce sera vlad qui
commentera en ma compagnie et vlad qui
est le second dans deux de great chauffe
donc y aura beaucoup de tension aussi
pour pour le match de mardi qui sera un
très très gros choc là où il y aura
vraiment deux joueurs du top top top
mondial puisque grille chouk était doute
triple changement de blitz et ils
avaient éliminé
maxime la saison dernière et de son côté
yann nepomniachi qui est aussi un des
tous meilleurs vie de soeur sur internet
donc on va dire qu'on va on va encore
élever le niveau élevé le débat mardi
pour le match est donc c'est reparti fab
lire proust en ouverture et dominguez
qui est de nouveau bien levé sur son
sillage un il a pas il n'a pas abdiqué
le cubain havane où il n'a pas d'ego
donc ça ressemble des stones et la faune
alors on dit que c'est le king quand tu
es allé voir un âne en gagnent face à
coussa coûtait 50 60 euros à moscou je
sais pas ce que j'allais avec vlad et
quand tu vas glad tu ne payes pas encore
tout coup passer ça te paye pour que ta
voiture en feu et oui donc né pauvre
icloud ce sera le premier vrai choc
après après mais aronian caruana on
pourra me dire ce qu'on veut tu vois
mais pour moi un runyan était quand même
largement au dessus ont vite mais belle
sur le papier c'est alléchant sur le
papier oui oui sur le papier c'était
alléchant mais mais génère pareil je
pense que l'epo a écrit tous que c'est
le premier match où tu peux même pas au
studio n'a pas de favori en pré match où
il lui fera quatre noms bizarres
ils sont consultés sur un sur trois
le serbe est 2 doigts de bras pour
éviter de se prendre le petit deux
contre un
par nature ans est l'une des six il
serait pas un peu mieux avoir et il veut
jouer 4 4 certaines ont su capturer le
fou ou kessé 8 qui est des 3 b 6
je vais mettre les clients d'esi ça
j'aime bien et b5 d'accord mais qu'elle
espère un jour tu attends on va le
mettre à moins que verser 6 maxime 17
jours jusqu'à ce qu'ils décident et puis
on prend et tous adhérents h6 il sera
pas si nuls et de fred 5e h1n1 va bien
mais il faut en justice donc le plus
haut niveau de fer avec cinq ans fatah
et éviter kg 5e ou 6e tandis que j'ai
pas relancer le chrono alors il se
trouve que en ce qui concerne le
chronomètre c'est pas moi qui suis je ne
suis plus responsable du chronomètre
il ya quelqu'un à cheste comme qui
s'occupe des chronomètres et donc c'est
lui qui a dû l'oublier le milieu très
bien merci pour elle cette nappe tête je
vais retourner 6 tombé à s'en prendre
aux pions des 600 prend option v7
ouais mais tous résistant au retour à 6
kraft sans que ces bons scénarios qui en
train de se profiler fab mais ont bien
sûr un trop petit trop bien il faut
qu'il essaye mais je sois tout racisme
sk risquons échangeant à 6 qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour bien on bloque l'option
b je pense qu'ils ont essayé de bloquer
le pion mais non c'est vrai quoi ton
problème
ouais enfin dire examen à ce genre de
pression avec les blancs j'ai
l'impression que je perds toujours sans
lutter des spectateurs que dure chez
votre comprendra du cube à 24 ans au
losc lui paraissent avoir un nightmare
qui demande bon soir quelqu'un peut
m'expliquer comment marche le tableau à
droite s'il vous plaît je suis un noob
des échecs
alors en fait c'est un match en qui dure
trois heures tu as les partis qui
s'enchaînent et le tableau que tu vois à
droite c'est le tableau du score en fait
donc les ce que tu vois le segment cuve
au milieu c'est la cadence à laquelle a
été joué c'est à dire le nombre de
minutes qui sont imparties aux deux
joueurs pour les parties et c'est le
score dans chaque cas danse et le score
en bas au total en fait c'est le score
du match celui qui a le plus de points
au total aura gagné le match et là le
chronomètre est pas relancer mais il ya
soixante minutes de jeu mais si jamais
il est parlant ces femmes gérer jeter un
petit coup d'oeil sur sur le au staff de
check point comme pour voir si si d'où
ça vient le père fois de suite je pense
bien garde de ne pas se prendre un truc
à kg 5 étoiles à nash à un moment donné
mais bon pour l'instant ça va via pas
dans deux coups sous le par
je veux a pris la fuite ou pas la
logique et la réticence
est ce que l'autre peut-être tentés du
cavalier h deux dames g4 d'alger système
aussi si tu fais ça et j'aurais mitrale
et cavaillon f1 pour couvrir et
tambourine big one for me pardonne les
caps sont actuellement fermés tu te fais
une cellule de deux joueurs en attaque
est un joueur au rock quoi qui les font
le roi ok maintenant cavalia se dote de
phase iii suivront pas tout le prendre
ce truc ou dames c'est un échec et trois
sur f3 il peut essayer de faire
d'amalgamé damas deux puis reprend j'ai
deux ou trois pions prend en charge tout
parce que peut-être on repasse adam en
f4 mais tellement à faire piéger trois
cabines f5 du coût gratuit donne la case
f 50 ans a quand même femme mme halimi
mais après ok tu pourras toujours si des
fois sacrifié g4 directives et le four à
rabat j'ai pas mes défauts ne sais pas
si clair nous sommes mais évidente cette
les manches sont mieux là en tout cas
c'est plus sympa mais pour les blancs
maintenant bon rien de nouveau dangereux
criminels qui arrivent comme en profite
pour fumer sur tourbe et 7 peut-être
qu'il va faire être 4 après s'active à
faire inscrire cela je pense avec les
gens
dans ma 4 aussi cette f4 et les
cavaliers 5 à peut-être cavaliers ap 5
et tue pas rend à 4 au dernier moment le
talent de michael schaerer
il a raté simple à temps
ces chauffards ya la dame qui m'arrive
manger sain croyais aussi bon iver dam
des cinq matchs non tu parles 0,6 me
suis planté donc j'ai cinq russell crowe
8 ans et d'un t shirt me fous et à la
tour qui doit absolument et sans à 7
pour arrêter de dangereux criminels mais
bon moi qui aimais droit prend l'état
deux doctrines et ces choses qualité là
ok d'aller voir son entraîneur
objectivement même je remets ta tombe de
rachel c'est sa jeunesse qui le fait
qu'un jusqu'à il aurait pu faire la caf
4 pour accélérer le la cadence quoi dont
je vous ai échangé cinq greffes a fait
mal c'est la femme elle fait mal bon ok
on campe à présent qu'il ya toujours
mieux mais aucun nom mais c'est tout
neuf c'est vraiment beaucoup a besoin de
batterie mais il a tellement bien joué
le q1 mais est normal de la marche du
roi le machin impérial le pain de martin
genest lerpt ce moment il savait pas été
très bons on roule vous mettez ainsi si
les peugeot sa top spin qui est content
et il le match est intéressant et serré
c'est pas comme quand il incarne scène
ou nakamura pas dire ce qui est marrant
avec un ancien des caméras c'est quand
même s'ils jouent contre n'importe qui
c'est passé récent toujours entre se
passèrent et non plus en fait c'est
carson social est quand même un caméra
non plus du coup puisqu'on met si je
vous conte quelqu'un ils gagnent pas
serré et si je construis garde
sanitaires pas serré
une idée qui avait été introduite par
rétine en ce truc de gamin je sais pas
mais c'est un truc qui veut j'en parlais
tout à l'heure a pris moins de 900
soldats approvisionner leurs le live
pendant la pause c'est dangereux il est
blanc soit un peu mieux donc tant mieux
ou la haye un mois ah ah ah ah il a
libéré il a libéré deux ouvrages médias
ça c'est des petits cheapos qui sont
[Musique]
après ce que c'est si grave je sais pas
sur quoi tu as droit un peu bizarre mais
il pas si faible
non vous êtes ça égalise ce qui était
quand même - ben ouais mais bon on a
permis d'encaisser les personnes
changent encaissé maintenant non voilà
vous marchez jonas et son volet attend
il refait une double attaque
après que double attaque 5 royal qui ne
prend aucune pièce que c'est un flou
total
marie va vraiment être beaucoup
attendaient que madame eu quatre échecs
et puis on français 4 il faut enfermer
agrafes points 6 rebonds prendra le fou
injuste par an non mais je suppose qu'il
faut dominer franchement je suis
impressionné par la tactique de 10 kg 4
non mais en partie longue c'est pas
assez dur à voir mes angles it
je vais annoncer deux grammes pour votre
palais ces deux tours c'est qu'ils
disent pas forcément bombay bel et bien
la réalité comme ben c'est pas assez
fabing maxime qui est en train
d'accélérer une ze5
il accélère bien ouais mais ce qui n'est
pas un truc que je fais moi de temps en
temps c'est juste ou tempo en fait tu
perds quoi rageante il s'agit juste de
jouer tempo pour faire semblant mais le
père d'anne des caps mais je suis à toi
de changer permal [ __ ] bon écoute c
j'ai vu le président guasch situe au
début du iii +12 dominguez sait qui
était et qui était bien réelle c'est
tout ça je suis [ __ ] le mec est encore
là et il te colle 2 0 d'entrée
maxime qui est pas bien rentrés dans le
jeu il n'est pas rentré dans le match
mais tu vois ça tu vois quand on parle
du montalet tous et on est soit en train
de rigoler sur la chaîne bat là tu vois
là mentalement il a été hyper fort 2002
voilà
cependant toujours ouest en temps je
suis en train de m'occuper du chrono je
suis arrivé en bas je reviens tard fnab
l'activité des fêtes c'est de la merde
c'est pas grave mais elle va gagner mais
on espère un mais voilà je tenais à
souligner comment parce qu'ils ont du
mental ou quoi ce que vient de faire
dominguez c'est une réaction de champion
femmes
c'est une réaction de quelqu'un qui a
été champion du monde et qu'ils cessent
pas marcher sur les pieds
et ça c'est beau faut le souligner qu'en
sahara il faut le souligner et unis
manquent pas mais je n'y manquerai pas
finie manquerai jamais bref c'est un
trop sûrement
la jarre position je me calme mieux les
blancs mais je sais que ça peut se faire
avec les normes
je vais essayer de remettre le chrono
c'est de faire entrer de partout assuré
même c7 et c6 pendant souffrance dans
trois plus
ok j'ai réglé le problème du chronomètre
11 ans j'ai demandé de l'aide au staff
et à toi dauphin truc pas tout à fait
mais une toute petite manip affaires pas
qui aurait pu marcher tout seul mais qui
n'a pas marché fin c'est le genre
c'était 50-50 quoi ça aurait pu marcher
sans le faire et enfin tu vois tu sais
que le streaming c'est une tonnelle oui
quand tu fais ça sur un ordi portable
dans ta cuisine oui c'est un art n'a
choisi je commence à avoir envie que ce
soit dominguez qui gagne madrid qu'est
ce que c'est que cette merde sur le
tchat mais je n'ai jamais d'être échangé
j'avais ouais non mais en fait moi je
suis content que le match soit serré
mais moi j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient
serré à +2 qu'on va faire ça fait chier
qui assure à monter non non mais c'est
intéressant savait qu'on a fait assez
chaud quoi mais c'est vrai que la
manière la manière de le dominguez c'est
rafraîchissant ça fait plaisir quoi
et puis tu vois fab ce nom pas souvent
aussi on en a marre de toujours voir les
mêmes joueurs elle avoir un mec un peu
nouveau qui tient en tête un mec du top
mondial c'est vrai que fais tu as un peu
séché catinot à roland garros quoi chez
qui pataugent pas comment il s'appelle
mais bon j'ai un mot non des montants
vie qui perdent quand même pas tu te dis
bon tu as très bien joué bravo tu a
éliminé aux cavs novak djokovic en
quarts de finale vont tuer fins il est
temps que tu ça suffit ah oui enfin je
retourne chez toi qu'en italie est un
beau pays
kevin aime beaucoup on va manger des
pâtes mais très bien l'italie ont fait
ce que je peux faire ce que je veux
d'origine italienne
j'ai tourné en plus donc je n'ai pas de
genre moi je
je compte peut-être déjà un tournant à
rome mais en décembre mais déjà que j'ai
pensé c'est lui je voulais m'en suis
très bon plat de pâtes ou amitié pas
arrêter toilettes orient fait aimer bon
descente sinon quand tu veux pas arrêter
joueurs jusqu'en janvier là tu t'es pas
déjà mis en route reprend un mois plus
tôt mais ta part tu fais pas la coupe
d'europe aussi qu'il est plus de
vacances foyer bon bah tu vois que les
factures marque par toi même que tu es
mais il va peut-être tenir maxime st bah
j'espère bien l'art est ce que je veux
dire c'est que tu as des cinq qui bon
mais tu dois de défendre deux fois et
les autres organisations dessin qui
prend papier c4 ou quad b6 et compagnie
ça soutient bien aimons l'édifice repose
sur des 5 mes5 peut-être demain être le
4-1 jours d'audience et qui sait que je
sais pas bon c'est pas aux sirènes
peut-être s'en mêle
voilà en somme ça tient sa fable je peux
suivre
on va voir ce qu'on va se prendre 4 un
jour parce qu'il prend pas mal tout
quatre aussi vite c'est beau mais
maintenant il va s'en prendre à tous les
pions blancs ce qui peut même pas être
mieux
non pas elle même justin de tout ça fric
aux libérateurs
c'est bien joué ce f4 pour pour se
gagner la casa f5
mais il peut la perdre ça la devine gaza
où tout est possible
moi je ferais bien phu detroit et les
cavaliers b3 pour fou pour les trois
quatre ou cinq rencontres
ouais mais je vous reprends prend et
cavaliers b3 et je me dis qu'un jour je
ferai du conte rejouer avec les u15 b c
c'est les trois points
ok on a envie de faire du bien ça ça va
beaucoup mieux la phase de 9,4 rebattu
les cartes
c'est triste on fout
c'est une pop aux montants le losc à ses
cartes
à yassa et maria des quatre qui tombait
au pied mais ok bon
des trois c'est pas forcément gagner
encore dans le hockey ça s'apprend comme
une bonne direction peut-être les
gagnants seront ceux qui les satisfait
un super job temps plus froid des 500
touché je crois donc voilà si incroyable
contre le cours du jeu il a évoqué ses
fils ok
en libres 1 4 maisons s'effondrent à
tavannes tombe sur le chien bappoo ça
tient mon dieu elle fait du bien ça la
fab elle fait du bien
ouais c'est inverse la savine marché qui
en dit du passé faisons table marbre
c'est chaud non mais recontre avec ça on
peut prendre les cinq hommes ont joué
trois peut-être qu'il a révisé pendant
la nuit
je pensais juste la chambre pour deux
sticks dolls et pour la cause mais ses
griffes ou que le fait aussi un message
gagner une pièce en fait qu'on va
déposséder faut s'y attendre mais riche
fait aussi à vlad qui l'appelle pendant
les pauses ou et une en inde où ça
n'empêche qu'on m'envoie il a révisé
mais est ce que c'est c'est bien ça
s'est réalisé que c'était de la merde
son truc
il est deux
mais je sais pas je vous renvoie votre
qui sortent cette ingestion bizarre mais
on peut être c'est pas si mal
on va voir non mais avance pas si mal ya
peut-être cavalli f4 il ya des trucs qui
tombe en bo3 trés pour moi je sais pas
ça très vite à l'heure mais je me disais
ce que c'est très comestible mais
attention je veux dire des trucs comme
ça
1 il ya tourné un match auquel assez
malin mais il est fort en fait ce qu'on
a mais j'ai trois ou on s'en va juste un
qe3
non seulement votre chien caracas salies
et des cinq juges issus des trois dépôts
potter vous êtes sûrs ressorte avec le
temps ces cinq étudiants le rige de
quillan ce sont les pieds l'essonne qui
est des trois mois qu'ils nous trouvent
encore un truc chelou l'inca et des
traces par herman kg si solidaires nous
propose de faire piéger 5 après mai / kg
on croit que ces 5 il ya peut-être des
quatre noms mais avec un coeur des trois
ouvriers forme c'est ça qu'il faut un
cahier là bas c'est chaud
donc il en est qui et c5 j'imagine
ok c'est intéressant tête g5 la fête
mais c'est peut-être un peu en poteaux
en plus ambitieux donc tout après 5
c'est peut être le mans ok à quatre ça
sécurise bien guéri c'est simple il faut
tu vas pouvoir bouger ton quai des 500
lits
je pense les blancs sont mieux la fable
meilleure structure de pions parce qu'il
ya un îlot de plus chez les noirs juin
m6 et au sein ou à chelsea que vous des
trucs comme ça bloquait un bon truc ce
que peuvent avoir un héros c'est ce qui
a agacé 6
ses responsables en de faire ça ouais je
suis
d'un autre côté les blancs vont perdre
pas mal de temps à récupérer b3 à tour
sera assez mal placé faut faire g5 et
après sur pions prendre des tours f5
tout retour ait fuité s'activent à fond
ou comme ça avec l'idée de faire du rhin
et g5 maintenant les jeunes mais j'ai 5
puis on prend je ne sais pas jusqu'où g5
comprend elle fait ça faisait pas grand
chose des cinq noms
bon on s'active et l'empêchent droit à
trois quand même ce qu'il y aura ces
trois y aura ces 3 qui sera en l'air si
un cavalier qui restent en a3 les
tourneurs pour donner tout tournait
autour des troncs ont détourné trois là
bien joués en bo3 et 5,1 à qui veut pas
voir tout robes des cas
bon mais c'est quand même toujours un
peu près sûr que au pire annuler quoi
s'attendent à voir mais en dépit des
actifs et c'est pas mal parce qu en fait
prises prix d'éruption c'est peut-être
pour ces deux tours c'est 6 tu vois oui
d'accord pour le point d'accord sur ce
changement à venir au logement ou h3
d'abord besoin grave que maxime il prend
beaucoup de temps forts à la fin de la
partie qui remarque way pour votre
précis
c'est marrant parce qu'il est capable de
jouer très vite au feeling des très bons
coups à la fin juste pour voir la
précision chirurgicale qu'on lui connaît
il prend le temps quoi
france 5 tout rejet de tout
hashcash ça ça je m'y attendais pas je
comprends même pas le coût quoi mais
maintenant ça cependant toujours pas je
lis vos fans sont deux exemples
hector des trois grands corps d'état
sont ils pourraient le faire un jour au
caire ouais mais aussi de ça va sauter
ouais mais peut-être surprend bessin
regrets et 36 pour prendre b4
ok mais bon c'est bien pour le bloc de
toute chose avance m
ils allaient encaisser j'ai rangé 3g 3 f
4 mai du push up ou soit comme ça c'est
mieux comme ça
en ce seul et ça gagne
vous réussissez tellement précis fable
c'est le h4 là qui est incroyable
d'avoir c'est peut-être tu es vraiment
su qu avec les 9,4 à reprendre la
colonne des troupes placebo sache 4
vraiment contre-intuitif une block
majorité et machins et on reprend plus
de fab way qui sont ses seins qu'elle
level femmes c'est impressionnant c'est
incroyable les mecs sont en train de
voir
c'est un niveau stratosphérique et le h4
il faudra revoir au ralenti quoi ça
demande un ralenti avec une caméra tu
sais quarante mille images seconde quoi
où tu peux vraiment bon style comment il
a calculé tous en 10 secondes elle est
enfin une et pas dans le top 10 mondial
pour sans raison un il n'a pas le même
cerveau que nous non tes dessins
moi j'aime bien et bien sortie de
l'ouverture ils échangent via ce qu'il
fallait et encore légalisé il reprend le
dessus et il a eu un passage à vide
non mais en fait la partie qu'il a gagné
la finale dans son théâtre mary tournant
comme ça ce qui était quand même bien
oui oui c'est sûr que c'est un tournant
c'est un tournant du match est
clairement ils somment ses partenaires
on dirait mais elle fait aussi preuve de
gros gros moral à aimer les 2 1 mais
juste enfin voyager souligné parce que
par dominguez comme il est moins
professionnels et les moins forts quoi
faire
normalement quand t'es pas favoris et qu
tu coules un peu c'était pas forcément
contre le cours du jeu mais un peu quand
même failli méritait pas tourner à moins
de non plus dans le cinq du sein je
pense et repartir comme ça c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident mais on peut
déjà mettre le condominium
mais bon tu connais de réputation nul
mais aussi bruzzone qui est très bon
dans les joueurs cubain cuba et le moins
bon domingues de se tenir à la vue de
ces partis on peut se demander quand
même s'il aurait pas pu avoir une
carrière plus plus fournie fab
il a fait un peu un ego tournoi oui mais
voilà ce pré palm oil pour le kg captera
schmitt mumbai les finales sont pour
rien je sais pas ce que tu dois faire
concerter avec les blues ça c'est pas
très appétissant la finale auxquels on
leur dit aimer pas du tout h 4 d'après
ce que je comprends à quelqu'un qui a
checké comme quoi c'est devait très fort
en pratique mais devait avoir un truc ça
semble plus trois fables un oui il ya
des que joann sfar tour d'allemagne du
couloir ya toutes les tactiques pour
construire quatre points 4
ça s'enchaîne mais du mauvais côté pour
le cubain on se dirige vers la tendance
négative alors tu peux peut-être faire
si on prend ces quatre jours ff12 que
mon hockey bon juste vous aux six déjà
c'est sûr c'est très bien autant faut
aussi ce qui est prend ses 8 oui mais
deux pièces le second wind ça suffit
mais bon peut-être mieux non mais je
veux vraiment vous pour ces cinq pour ce
soit qui ait des cinq je pense qu'il
fallait faire rien attendre du genre de
pièces depuis il l'a fait dans ce sens
là c'est mieux non pas par hasard si on
bat seul talent pions décor est un
dangereux criminel quand il est là qu
elle se rivent quoi tu as they dangereux
criminels tout le temps ça c'est parti
sur la côte et en la marque mode autour
des 6 très bien dans le pion de francs
ainsi sous peu au passage la fsg
s'inclinant psg 5e qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
forts fab
il roulait les pièces elles sont
généralisés 24 et ça pousse ça pousse
cav a lieu quatre mêmes ou telle
technique
je pense qu'avoir un abonnement un
abandon lors de travaux
plus 3 il ya eu un petit frisson et puis
c'est reparti il sert fait son
acquisition les 800 spectateurs faut
dépasser largement les 1000 pour le
match 45 à roanne aurait mais ça en
plein après midi
alors qui sait il ya des des partages
c'est des matchs est chaud il y en a
sûrement du monde vient y avoir des 1500
3000 mêlant blues la cadence y prête ses
parties rapides machin c'est sympa oui
puis c'est un match très agréable un
prêt et j'ai six de nos docteurs bon il
va pas se reprendre
il faudrait aussi je veux à un peu peur
moi je sais mais gerbal serait génial
qui se reprenne exactions un truc de
petit type femme un bain sexy
merci il n'y a pas de petite musique
qu'on ait besoin d'un temps pas un
moulin et si moi j'entends c'est toi qui
tu l'entends pas en fait non c'est
normal je ne me dis qu'ici aussi quoi
ouais mais ça c'est pas c'est pas envie
de rejoindre ses amis on me mettre en
joie
j'aime bien cette musique ouais mais je
peux pas te la mettre sur ton ordi en
fait je veux pas la jouer à fond la
caisse et je l'entends au micro non ça
va faire un jour des faits larsen un
truc puis en plus gelé par la voix en
fait la musique
non je veux pas tu ne peux pas te
musique est quoi
du coup zénéral est qu un petit pour nos
demandes
c'est un don on attend sur une cagnotte
quoi la can you tu as pour soutenir la
chaîne ma chaîne des stream sur youtube
enfin partout en fait il est sûr surtout
erice et là partout la team bitstream de
l'entreprise afin qu'une entreprise
madame la honda les entreprises dans le
sens de sociétés et entreprises dans ce
sens une entrée marche l'esprit bistrot
tyco pas si c'est parce que je garde
tous les souks ou alors est ce que les
piscines
est ce qu'il ya des paquets f6 c'est fou
prend 1,4 à parler du coup sûr
surtout reprend j'ai cinq balles dont
l'un qui pousse une envolée dangereux
cumul de barco métal à 4 à 3 guaino
qui est tombé 5 intermédiaire fera rien
quand il y aura fou attaque la tour est
ok donc tu veux à 4 à 3 et le cas il y
aura plus de casque le foot va devoir se
remplissent ce refus en d1 est ok il
fait quand même qu'ils apprirent à cette
pas mal d'options
le tirage de trois pions devons nous
battre et je vais très bien la tour en
c2 quand même je ne changerai pas perso
mais notre jeu se veut un jeu pas sûr en
fait
d'après décision vite un maximum
l'entraînement mais on ne savait pas où
nous sommes je pense sa stratégie à
maxime de jouer vite
ok faire gaffe à pas se prendre cinq
tours de math aller juste 5 ça peut être
chiant non mais là je pense que t'as pas
vraiment les compensations pour pour
pièces mais bon non mais clairement pas
non non et du coup on fait quoi fab ont
remboursé on est on est mécontent
when he is matt voilà ce matin
on
ce que tu fais jouer ça pour partir se
trouvent ces 3 le truc c'est que sur
tourbe et c'est tu pourras faire tour
ces trois tours détroit mais tant que ça
trop d'excès voire même les deux
d'ailleurs fait si on prend fou ici
c'est sûrs et tu vas j'ai assez la tour
et n'importe qui l'a vu le maintenant
c'est sûr mais tu vois dominguez une
nouvelle fois quand tu penses que quand
tu penses que tu t'en débarrasser
il a encore montré dangereux sat de st
merci merci encore je vais regarder qui
s'est massé a personnellement je paye le
plus tôt la personne précédant les
grands noms mais tu as faim tu ne veux
pas dire la personne précédente c'était
oui certes donc merci à wil frère tu est
cette personne là c'est zacharias et zac
du goût la zac
merci ça vous inquiète par tous partout
et nous a tous les stages mais il assure
le type mais partout
alors
c'est pas encore gagné
un truc si tu peux te prendre un tour
fou contre tours cet échange les tours
là c'est facile à gagner cette finale de
pions donc tour à quatre mois ou c'est
moi qui déconne parce qu'en fait tu
pourras un dieu vers le même but que toi
tu mets leur on veut cette louange et 7
mois ressort jambes en coton ici
j'allais dire et côté hockey je mettrai
le front ces deux de commencer pareil
sur walf 4 je m'entendais 6 et j'ai
toujours su réagir si celle ci sera
longue de 3 ok on aurait gagné pareil et
du coup tu vas devoir lâcher les cadeaux
5 louarn merkel veut voir avec cela
du coup il s'est redressé de votre
chaise mans maintenant il est revenu
faire plus qu'à 2 points à 21 2 - 2 1 et
à trois noms mais il agit coupe à quoi
il coupe ah
non non ça reparte sympathique thaler il
était bien il était qui sait si cette
fin juin qui a été sept pareil il est
méritoire qu'elle efficace et saddam ces
deux jeunes vers la 3d bizarre et on
pensait plutôt à b3 carte des trois
tours bien à 300 soit finalement fait sa
soute âge puissent quand tu fais mes 3 à
3 tours ben tu prends à quatre jeux
pressure f4 le fonds est indienne
voilà où que m6 a mené sur qui je pense
est sait plus quand même j'ai juste
envie de voir une attaque rageuse mais
va peut-être faire [ __ ] mais bon on a
pas le classement je me rends au genre
d'attaqué est génial il a priori concept
ok et fils de fer ont fait cai j'allais
dire qu'ali g5 et désiré 4 comme ça non
parfois aussi ceux qui aussi bon boitier
fier ce qui change tout et puis tu fais
b6 et tu fermes et maisons non plus
qu'il en soit tranquille
d'alès on espère que j'enlève cent
quinze jours mais je sais pas si cette
anecdote
tout juste f3
ce que truc cité chanson leucate et tu
reprends du purin jour n'est pas
mécontent avec les blancs par la spla il
ya quelques échecs où elle fera ou non
votre look et ben non je veux dire
breaké pour le cas john prend machin
phoebé six duos lord finale comme ça pas
mauvais fou c'est tout bon pied le truc
c'est à tellement de pions sur la même
case c'est pas grave en fait c'est ce
truc là c'est que j'ai demandé non mais
ce soutien très bien bush ne peut pas
prendre battery mode qu'est c'était
quand même un peu content non non je
changerais tout
très vite
et peuvent même faire du direct non
marie va essayer que les blancs quand
même c'est logique ils vont fermer le
flou avec jets sainte
ouais 37 taille tu passeras jamais en
fait c'est impossible
des fois tu as le c5 c6 qui est chiant
mais la pièce présente je crois que ça
va aller tu vas mieux ses 8 et tu
attends pas c'est pour ça qu'il veut pas
fermer avec g5 de la comprendre
si tu vas à quatre lits de frein jour
des 5 rbds et 4 et prendra mais j'ai pas
une dose et changé non plus donc je
pense me faire approuver dirhams devant
le bain marie clément tu peux rien faire
basse et 5 sauf chez étape mais on
frappe des français mais français et
puis on touche plus on saigne ça tombe
bien joué quand même la part de
dominguez mais il a un peu courant
maxime si le domine bien il le contient
bien quoi si dans un score nul dans ce
cas nulle part comme les points chacun
en fait dans la partie compte pour un
spécial
michael c
ces cinq prochains mois bon vous en
privez pas à passer avec laurent qu il
va revenir aussi forte voire impossible
pour le 6e rang machin dont on non non
c'est fini
enfin y'a pas de le fou des huit bien
placé le pion v6 un peu faible mais
c'est faux qui tient et tu peux pas je 0
idée là j'ai cinq gars jouer en fait tu
as pourri encore plus s'en fout mais tu
sais pas grave je tiens tout tu as fait
rage ici c'est différent
alors peut-être que dominguez en profite
pour un peu récupéré non quand tu vas
sur la caméra il a l'air de chercher
ouais lekuta rudisha parce que ok bien
coûte 4 ans comme carl sanaa bien s'est
pas très bien passée mais il a quelque
chose qui n'ont peut-être juste en
croatie scénique heures passent et les
pauvres s'est passé peut il faut juste
comme ça et fmb sain de vivre c'est la
partie que maxi avait perdu contre eux
comme ça contre manu souhait et c4 c4
serrar pas mal ton poids toujours plus
d'argent dans le faire ok mais ces mêmes
idées ont besoin de points
qui est tombé huit fins ces dossiers
tous dans le même esprit en fait c'est
de jouer sur le clouage et vous pouvez
prendre le plus de dégâts on peut grand
buzz autour des rançons payées se
trouvait attaque et que tu préfères tu
peux pas combien l1 il ya dame française
devrait être le truc c'est que les noirs
ont un problème ce que par ok ça marche
compte que très bon et ça va compliquer
le jeu grâce auquel cas où j'allais te
parle un français 3 6 devant le roi de
chômeurs était de faire rodez lui 3,6 ce
que j'allais dire finir là on fait du
froid des 8 sera fou j'ai quatre looks
et toi aussi souvient ah oui parce qu'au
moins il n'a pas le temps de faire face
surtout reprend me trouver n'importe
quoi ni de votre taille avait le matin
qui restait donc ça me prenait trop de
temps
est ce que fout du sein maxime tu veux
qu'elle réalise et 4 1 pour déloger la
tour ou même des quatre kamikazes non
mais c'est jamais évident en quad sera
au centre de ce nom mais tu es forcément
mieux ou pas je n'aime pas sûr en fait
j'ai lu sur les troncs pop ce qui des
fois je passerai option b 2 pour jean
peu qu'on serait en fait moi j'ai jamais
ça suffit je joue parce que jamais un
geste position là mais tu vois je me dis
pas ça suffit tu vois et s'ils ont aussi
chez 5 comme renoir se souvient un peu
je t'aime et tu pourras j'aime rien d'un
structure mais ça peut être un jour vide
va trouver 5
ouais merde planète se dit je prends
prend et d'alves ces trois bateaux sont
vos droits et ce fardeau qu'est tombé 4
c'est non non vous lâchez la callas je
pense pas que ce soit une option pour
rich iott n'est pas trois noms alors la
fuite est tenu la dame tient à tours à
fuir notent donne des deux veut partir
c'est leur problème je pensais d'entre
eux sont souvent je pense qu'il est très
mal d'amis gaza non merci chansons aussi
parce que là il se fait prendre à revers
après il peut faire voir et 8 laissé le
pion mêlée à cinq
et sur quels points à 5 bah tant pis
demoitie change en bien
j'attends un peu petit roy s'est vite où
je gagnais pas la dame qui arrive
directement de pas tarder non chez ben
non c'est infernal
pas trop quand il veut tenir sa hâte de
faire tomber vite repartir je me suis où
il va se faire mater en quelques coups 7
6 c'est fini c'est fini ou presque
madame un vide qui et b6 d'un
tromboniste maintenant darin tu vas
faire brasser sem
non mais y avait un truc qu'on pense aux
forces économiques et bien système prend
v8 et qu'elle prend 17 qui aurait fait
une fourchette royal ça va on reprend
trois points puis il reprend sa chance
dans un âge nord mais là ça va faire ça
à faire trop faible pour un pour
sébastien j'ai l'impression que que
sébastien pages façon tous sebastian
donc 1
du coup je me dise oui ça fait sébastien
quoi ben en fait c'est lénine au vernis
ouais mais bon peut-être que je sais pas
peut-être que son nom ait pas accomplir
j'en sais rien tu as many quand même
sebastian n'a aucun rapport avec lui oui
femme de patrick malval à la fois qu'ils
en fassent tourner des serviettes vu
revenir les six vols en chine
l'histoire c'est qu'une mouche ça me
saoule je suis peut-être deux premières
parties oui la partie eric c'est le
prénom de son fils oui gbagbo c'est son
pseudo donc on peut l'appeler sébastien
sur le hockey mais ça faisait des trucs
un précieux mais sans trop le savoir
d'affilée à cheng est complètement sûr
il ya bien un machin
non mais ce maquis joue à quoi pour le
moment il joue à pas grand chose au
final
non mais déjà une plus grande vitesse
d'exécution vin de chez maxim général
cet avantage autant c'est toujours
quelque chose d'important
c'est un peu mieux préparés dans les
ouvertures et sinon ouais malade ou pas
trop sur un territoire mais bon à sac
les italiennes en quoi c'est un problème
là pour 1 2 milliard a visé son truc
mais on sait toujours pas trop ce que ça
qu'est la nage d'or fait sien ok mais je
crois que la personne est mieux préparé
que maxime dessus jamais mme kroes
magnus tu vois il joue pas v6 qui est le
gros coup il fait à saintes
cette innovation va innovation
improvisation mais après la joue très
bien à compagnie peut sans être rapides
et profonds télé connectée
non mais le match au volant c'est
justement que je veux pas analysé la
race de l'animal
vous savez les plus dangereux c'est une
mousse ça me va il peut voler de révolte
au québec des côtes ont tardé tour fait
elle ressort pour une fenêtre elle
revient par l'autre ça est une mouche
non pour être taries comme ça je pense
mais bon ok du coup je peux plus suivre
les et chaque cas chez le chanteur
temouchent et bons centres et envoyé pas
mal
ce sera pour pour vous tous 2015 il m'a
l'air de paris a joué là celle-là c'est
intéressant c'est pour maximum toujours
du joueur c'est un peu genre de pression
de match ouais ferme les fenêtres mais
après je prends sauna quoi du coup il ya
des problèmes partout pour finaliser du
coup fait avec ce que ce pion passé b ce
serait pas dangereux qui menace exercée
blanc jamas ah cautionnement qui tient
bien le truc bon merci mutation et
continue de vitesse de l'éclair ils
t'envoient avec pièce là bas mais
quand même avec les blancs il a accéléré
la cadence avec les blancs ce qui n'est
pas il n'est pas si loin autant cette
fois ci n'ont objectivement tous très
bien qui est alors lié au taux de faire
du dom des photographes 3,2 à chaud
comme ça mais bon on va dire on n'y
croit pas trop trop trop on n'y croit
pas du tout mais il manque un fou de
cases blanches bundles est beaucoup trop
quand même prendre moi j'aime je me
disais ce que je fais dams et 7 avec les
blancs tu vois je te dis bon je vais pas
tout vous êtes suffirait s'est fait
damer fuite et ça marche dames de cette
norme et le papillon prend 1,4 toutes
ces options est même l'un des musiques
direction prendre un point à 3,4 et ça
peut pas fonctionner mais après en blitz
qui je puisse y avoir des dames c'est
cette maintenant et cavaliers chahid 6
mai 6 kg 4 broches
sur dame franchi cet effroi m'a tuer sa
femme laura la dame est ce que est ce
que de mingan va venir comme carrie
salir par ben bella attention de bien
calculer trouble et cela restera un rêve
qui a troqué intéressant voilà qui est
super et roy dupuis l'orage et 2 ouais
je dois me prend h3 juste en guest il
n'y a pas de père fait puisque d'objets
4h 2 et n'est donc manger de ses sept
mois on sait que quand ça s'ajuste peut
être tous les problèmes il arrêtera
contre matin c'est calme ne peut pas
changer
là ça semble très compromis femmes on va
prendre maintenant police et suivies par
les serbes
t'as même pas vraiment le temps de voir
quand tu content parce que c'est 3 2 au
6 mai c'est flou que mais il arrive à
trouver des ressources
ouf maxime peut-être la perte quand même
mais un truc complètement raide
il passe par ces cautions là où tu es
peu un accord de paix rhdp est ok non
non non mais c'est pas n'importe qui
ferment c'est maxime vachier lagrave
j'aimais quand même hein c'est pas fou
mais le carillon et 3 et super bien
placé
quand tu es notre fin de match 8 2 me
soit pas possible je regarde mais pas
moins qu'un bon toujours plus d'autres
ont même noté ça reste avant tout casser
il y faut quoi parce que contre maxime
défendre sa faim tu vois il sait pas il
s'est quasiment jamais fait magouiller
mais a fait peut-être que s'il sait que
claude dubois reese est vraiment tout
exprès pas loin d'aller tout à l'heure
c'est pas beau mais en fait un bon jeu
dim du match c'est vraiment là où vous
l'avez meilleure position via feydeau
sur deux c'est vrai qu'ils tendent pas
un petit fois à six ans après vous vous
de vous la crise ce que là tu fais un
petit sou après tu as il après move je
fais ici nightclub qua non mais ça se
tente non plus sans pilote mais bon ça
c'est vraiment pas de chance
je pense vraiment que ces mouches
qu'elle vienne sur l'écran bien
j'écoutais été c'est la can des joueurs
qu'on a femmes 1
priorité quand même on me vois pas avec
la mouche non c'est toi tu tournes à un
peu les trucs ouais là j'ai un peu tout
abandonner mais là j'ai quand même
laisser les joueurs de pierre maxime ils
sont tous les deux mis un cadre et je
veux c'est sympa depuis ne peut encore
dire une seule chose
non non non enfin su assez
du coup n'oubliez pas vous pouvez
partager parce que là il va avoir les
bullet qui vont démarrer et à la cure et
ça va être très spectaculaire n'oubliez
pas de partager se faisait sur des
forums sur des machins de partout parce
que là ça va vraiment être à s'arrête
chaud puisque même si c'est plus trois
fins turbulette tout peut arriver
il suffit juste un peu fatigué ou quoi
et il me semble que dominguez quand il a
accéléré le jeu en début de partie tu
vois il n'a pas trop et pas la main qui
tremble nom et son niveau de jeu m'a pas
l'air d'avoir demandé c'est peut-être
qu'il aurait eu intérêt à jouer plus
vite dès le début après j'en sais rien
tu as dis ça je dis rien avec 10 pts en
5 minutes vous attendez si tu cherches
un bouchon j'arrive je vais vouloir la
voir rentrer et de faire mais on va voir
bats toi voilà cette finale on a déjà vu
plusieurs il faut faire entrer dans
cette même finale
maxula qu'un vrai avantage des espaces
cette fois ci je pense qu'il est mieux
mais jamais simple diabolique a
fonctionné à les parties je suis
tellement heureuse - je veux un petit
lien si vous voulez partager avant avant
les bullet remarquons et 800 mais il ya
qu' il n'y a que y'a que cinq partage
c'est bon je l'étais fuir quoi il sera
au final ça fait quand j'ai ouvert la
porte d'entrée
mais [ __ ] tourner en rond et on se
dira c'est intéressant là bas ok elle
est partie mais le temps que je referme
la porte et la cam fait son retour mais
j'ai senti qu'elle est intéressée et la
fois d'après je vais passer sa chance
est sorti j'ai claqué quoi très
intelligent du coup elle peut voir
passer par la fenêtre les pieds à moi
qui capte dans un couloir que des fêtes
pour revenir mais bon à ce moment là
autant pisser travaux trop fort pour moi
le couple est tu la laisses vif y est
one enfin tu lui dis bon écoute je te
prends comme seconde en toi tu es
beaucoup trop de jus secondes et navara
mais c'était pas beaucoup mieux t'aimes
pas trop cette réputation que vous avez
le souci d'avoir ajustements id sépare
d'eux les rôles store via d'autres
cultures c'est pas avec vlad lui
demanderez à mardi pour le commentaire
contre gries tchouk monde donnant une
juste nul rageant c'est que personne
n'avait en fait vous en priver mais a
dit plusieurs fois à chaque fois précis
je pars abandonné gritche qui avait fini
tu as une nouveauté qui était
possiblement enfin réfuté tu pouvait
égaliser évoqué fait gris turquie l'a vu
contre damas rap et l'allemagne mais je
puis dire pour la partie aucune chance
qu'ils trouvent le mec a vraiment pas
trouvé quoi va pas mais bon retour que
c'est génial d'être une fenêtre dans le
couloir que faire retour quoi vous one
by sa place d'ici bas je suis modeste
parce que des 3 es joueur tu as
peut-être te prendre celle ci avec
jaillir un truc de fou et genre des
trois pions prend à trois des quatre
fous ces quatre voiliers français 4 à 2
et tu fais le chat mais du coup je me
demande c'est quoi la défense ne fait
pas mal jaser je me garde gagner mais
bon enfin maxime ans gens tranquilles
voleurs la vitesse de l'éclair et de
réfléchi lorgne un truc vers un piège au
moins aussi malin que quelqu'un bouge
elles étaient deux bush qui en appelle
moi c'est aussi con que ça mais je me
demande si ça gagner pas ton truc hein
ça me paraissait
je comprends les montes se dit qu'ils le
gardent des proies tu le gardes tu peux
gagner direct quatre cavaliers katché
pas mais ça marche ça marche on voudrait
merci mais bizarre tu reviens vers ces
trois sets ok après à la fatigue aussi
femmes 1
le roi reste toujours dans le cas
réduction eux-mêmes silva en bo5 c'est
important parce que c'est à dire que les
f-5 si on prend le 6 mars ba mais bon là
qu'il prend b53 francs bay 5-3 et 4,44 à
b2 donc roi des trois rois cc3c 3-0 ab
car je pense il ya r5 parce qu'on fait
bien dame pacha
car est ce qu'il doit faire trois des
cinq étapes et télé qui ont un
cafouillage trois maîtres très fort les
mains écoute n'est plus qu'à moi c'était
la dernière partie en croit plus à
elecam nasa eh ben bon ok part à cause
de la mouche de ginette du couloir
je pense à prendre des clés pour ya max
qui est en train de rigoler mais je sais
pas si rigole pas un peu jaune bon ok
tout reviendra plus fort j'apparais
c'est pas le genre de mec a quand même
tenu maximum 5 + 1 et 3 plus simplement
dire pour un mec qui retraités facile
c'est vraiment pas un c'est vraiment pas
un hasard s'il ya quelques années il ya
il ya maintenant une dizaine d'années
quand il était encore jeune et tu peux
être champion du monde public
bah ouais mais c'est pas au nom d'un
dieu c'est pas un peu par hasard à les
mecs
enfin c'est tendu un fait franchement
domingues qui nous offre une très très
très belle résistance mais je pense que
maxime va va passer la surmultipliée en
bullet et va réussir à faire le à faire
l'écart le formule est ça doit être
maxime donc je remets un lien pour les
partagent les mecs franchement si vous
vous aimez les échecs vous connaissez
les gens qui aiment les échecs la petite
demi heure là qu'on va se faire de deux
bulles est ça va être ça va être très
sympa un point d'écart tout et tout est
encore jouable mais le papy papy fait de
la résistance
papy domingas fait de la résistance
c'est chaud c'est même très chaud
mais bien malin qui peut prédire le
vainqueur maxime favori mais c'est loin
d'être évident
c'est loin loin loin loin d'être évident
on va bien voir
on va bien voir comment ça se termine
alors
enfin petit facebook
alors ça va repartir je suis juste
d'écrire ce truc et je suis là
poursuivre avec vous cette demi heure de
match allez hop c'est fait on est
reparti les mecs
alors il a voulu le b 4 assez tôt je
pense ça assez bien joué ils évitent ces
je vais remettre la chrono à les chronos
tiers partis dominguez qui a empêché ses
cinq cette fois ci je pensais je pense
qu'il doit discuter entre des partis
avec caruana ou avec quelqu'un j'en suis
quasi quasi convaincu il a offert comme
comme la team vlad allegri tchouk je
voulais parler non mais il est partie
s'est levée et j'imagine que ce que ces
cantons commun de fait va dit par
pendant les pauses il va il va parler
greening d'edwin je reviens fallait
donner quelques conseils je vais lui
expliquer comment jouer
donc pour le l'algorithme duchess comme
dont 74% de chance à maxime de remporter
le match toujours
alors c'est vrai que maxime va envoyer
du jeu à l'e3 fab si peu ouais c'est
aussi un peu fermé et pas si simple
5h04 n'est plus aussi ça m'a peut être
séduire non plus ou bien peut-être
qu'elle est à 3 kg et cdn look et ouais
mais on a 2 ou 7 à 4 6 4 m de faire
maintenant à fait fou des 5 maxime qui
est un peu mieux au temps comme tout au
long de ce match
pour moi c'est vraiment ça qui aura fait
la petite différence c'est cette petite
célérité qui est qu à maxime en milieu
de jeu bon ben j'ai toujours j'espère
que tu as aimé le mot que j'employais
quoi célérité sécurité dommage de devoir
surveiller firme la porte
ouais m'excuser pour des fous projet 80
garder un jour et damages de encore tout
le monde souffre énormément déçu une
propos de nul de maxime et ça fait nul à
les deux minutes de jeu de moins fin
c'est une partie une partie plus proche
maxime qui mène toujours d'un point pour
le mondial 2-6 fab
mais il va pas falloir féminine va pas
voir faiblir un 10 minutes de
déconcentration et c'est fini on passe
par la fenêtre un petit peu comme la
mouche non mais est toujours là mais bon
elle pourrait passer par la fenêtre un
petit peu d'inattention elle prend la
fenêtre elle peut plus revenir apprécié
elle se perd tu vois on the dogs il
pleura pu aggraver le truc des dessins
animés en fait moi je me fends fameux
dehors la moue chose dedans
elle se marre s'arrêter marrant
effectivement elle aurait pu venir
commenter le match
alors ça va vite fab
c'est difficile de comprendre ce qui se
passe mais les cases blanches paraissent
faibles risques à faire tout rage suite
h5 gk h 5 h 4 et se dire qu'ils couvrent
toutes parts il est dangereux ce cubain
un fab il est dangereux ce cubain il
tarde regarder jouer
il a tous les coups du tennis les vrais
échecs avec 800 voix mais attention la
fourchette
je pense pas qu'il soit très bien mais
bon c'est l'hérésie chagos respectueux
encore une minute que les croisés menace
prise très célèbre rallye domine bien si
on est parti hier de fétan g4 en enfer
en ai dis toi qui as du mal contre n'y a
qu'un c'est juste pour remettre en
perspective
pas reprend force normalement dû peu
pareil c'est fini il a oublié ça c'est
vrai ce qui est bien tenu mais ouais ça
se dégrade
oui mais bon adoma fin très bien quoi
fins scientifiques même est géré par
l'aïe
bon je pense ça va le faire femme je
pense à le faire aller c'est vrai c'est
la énième fois que j ça dans ce match
mais +2 la pizza sur ce qu'ils montrent
des devis 2 bref c'est ce qu'avaient
prévu les algorithmes bizarrement alors
ils avaient prévu une légère victoire en
cinq puissantes domingas et légères
victoire en 3 +12 maxime qu'il menait
avec un petit avantage avant le bullet
et je pense qu'ils donnaient le match à
+4 pour maxime tu vois c'est plus ou
moins le scénario qu'on est en train de
vivre
mais pourquoi tant général chauffeur qui
viennent chez speedway
je crois que c'est une surprise une
femme
donc ouais enfin c'est une vraie
surprise déjà les peaux qui barrent
oignons ou un truc comme ça m'a surpris
mais c'était ça répare des connexions en
fait n'en ai jamais eu de surprise non
c'est parce que tu as même pas besoin de
jouer le match
oui on va tu as gagné bravo toyer ce
match
non mais ça manque un peu de surprises
quoi ce format non mais le truc c'est
que là on est très content mais en fait
le problème c'est qu'à au prochain match
savoir la surprise cette fois même
process is ova faire tourner chaque
projet de change et des taux pour 24h 24
même si adam et ans et 6
rémi reiss française barak et maxime
ambühl est celle dont 42 femmes minces
et ça c est fou prend prise d'armes
français si ses tournées un échec de
déviation moi j'ai eu des changements de
plans d'options a très bien madame se
racontent des gonades couvre autant
droite est le pion à pousser mais bon
maxime tout le temps devant autant un
très important là d'autant plus fins
encore plus maintenant que dans les
autres
et dans ce bon état juste d'apprendre à
me tordre éviter un message époque et on
est bien loin du foot huppert a cinq qui
se fait t si content de l'équilibré tout
ça à fond tout le sacrifie à l'effet
retour de d'un mètre de neige et de matt
jordan des troyens faire tourner
oui c'est fantastique mais une question
toute simple comme ça on peut hélas
total actuellement à 7 ou encore de taux
ramenés à demain peut-être ok toi roi
3-1 veille pour apprendre à s'en sortir
on a tous à bâle aurait fallu qu'ils
démarrent avec 2,3 points d'avance
mémoire et comme je dis moi j'ai déjà vu
une fois c'est dans l'est dans l'est
en fait dans les gènes battles et des
joueurs un peu moins fort les mecs avec
très fort un métier mais qu'à 2006 entre
eux quoi et du coup il était déjà arrivé
d'avoir des surprises en budget avec un
mec qui s'écroulait quoi mais le truc
c'est que c'est pas ce n'était pas le
même niveau qu'à des matchs de grand
maître
mais c'était deux mecs à 2006 quoi bah
oui plein on vit les merdes peut-être
encore bien sorti d'ouverture mais bon
la différence de niveau est pas si
énorme non mais un petit truc
l'attendent pilule du match n oubliez
pas que vous aussi vous abonner à la
chaîne chaise com fr c'est un petit
follow me fait toujours plaisir
ils ont une chaîne youtube aussi
d'ailleurs ouais on pouvait suivre de
partout d'ailleurs je leur faire des
petites vidéos sera différent de ce que
je sois sûr avec toi sur des stream mois
moins fouillé quoi est ce qu'on peut
dire moins bien bah oui non enfin oui
c'est plutôt dédié au format 10 minutes
à moins de tendance dans le détail mais
après pour ceux qui aiment ce format là
ce sera mieux pour eux voix s'élèvent en
fait je ne sais pas ce que je veux dire
c'est que moi pour moi c'est mieux passé
un moment à mieux le défricher la
position tous à un besoin mais sera pas
le cas tout le monde parle et que toi tu
ni moins bien
je vend très bien le truc au pouvoir
allez-y
alors comment follow the path to follow
sol est en dessous quelque part en
dessous à droite tient à coeur y avoir
un car quelque part c'est pour cinquante
et une seconde il écrase sa position en
plus toi moi c'est fini après ça va trop
vite pour le duo de criminels est trop
fort maintenant ce pas fini encore
mathieu sat est en croissance
il ya un mini match que ça ils assoient
tour théâtre jeux dessins voilà 17 g ici
souffrent j'ai ici c'était cet échec
bah vous vous trouvez ça commence à
prendre forme de simples ça commence à
transforme +3 ça commence à prendre
forme
nadja de la piste rome mais là en plus
le dynamique des partis là il n'y avait
plus rien dans les autres doigts des
feuilles peut être convient devoir
défendre comme toujours le qui pousse
pierrot mieux japonaise il fait une
nulle de souffert non puis il ya aussi
le fait que plus ça avance moyen de
temps pour revenir
la rs pris énormément de partir dans le
match g5 qui paul dike en fermant deux
tours
ouais mais ça va trop vite dominguez qui
essaye de suivre le rythme de maxime
mais ça va trop vite
pas assez fort il tente un truc c'est
une tour comme il semble être même pas
parti vite gagné matériel trac c'est
sûrement mieux que ton fond c'est abou
issa maintenant autant pour déblayer
tout ça parce qu'on ne m'arrête pions la
mévente les cb4 encore une belle
démonstration c'est mieux et quand même
choisi imagine que naka est encore plus
fort c'est parce qu'ils s'imaginent le
niveau et le magnus est encore plus fort
que n'a qu'a donc je sais pas c'est
quand y pense c'est parce que là ça va à
une vitesse c'est hallucinant et en tue
support est à mener 5-1 se défendre son
arrivée tour 8,44 plus intéressant c'est
le cubain là qui est en train de tuer en
train de baisser sur sa chaise rien
faire là tout va du coup j'aimerais me
voir maxime double pingouins pas sûr
qu'ils battent le pingouin pense que
c'est bon c'est pas sûr en plus simple
tête mais en un + 0 c'est pas sûr mais
nous lé pas que le pingouin et c'est un
des seuls qui réussit à tenir contre
magnus à y tient oui mais non mais doit
être si le joue à force il doit le
battre mais mais le pingouin est plus
fort que dominguez par exemple c'est sûr
monde mais avec un poussin 1 0 c'est de
voir des gens mac os 10.6 bien joué en
08 mais en plus un avec arsène plus fort
mais à +1 1% a vu la différence
chaque année l'équipe pingouins buzz
chez pas ses incursions international
andrew dingue dingue c'est un pari qu'on
fait c'est un spécial un vol autour de
mille cinq cents lots emportés dans le
match en main il est monté à 25 60
mais voilà on 8 5 5 minutes ou 3 minutes
où il joue pas mal mais en fait en
note il va hyper vite après le truc à
souligner c'est que le mec va même pas à
faire genre d'échec on espère faire des
études il va rentrer après une star une
l'année prochaine ce soir débute sans
foyer résiste pas mal le cubain se
rendre l'esprit de ses cinq fils de m
c'est l'autre qui avance un bilan crois
pas bien mais de nouveau ses chiens qui
ont précédé la colonne ouverte de pro
maxime équivalent terme et thé puis on
passe enfin ton qui ont dépassé et tu
vends b tellement n'évite c4 et les
blancs resta chine d'options pas mal et
il tentera sa chance en pratique c'est
bien me faire attaquer jusqu'à c'est une
tour qui revient sur la colonne g machin
tour au captage et 4.3 bien jouer
défendent bien mais là il franchement il
se bat bien dominé à smith va même pas
suffire mais c'est bien c'est fait il
cherche de toute pratique les dames
n'est jamais qu'à ta un tel sentiment
d'impuissance pour dominguez
pourtant il s'est vraiment battu lille
et cherche la chance il s'est pas fait
la police s'est s'écrasé que c'est dans
le club tony mesdames des terroirs ce
domaine ouais c'est ça prend forme se
formait le maintenant voilà y'a quoi ya
cinq points d'écart
ouais cinq points d'écart traduite à
jouer une victoire et c'est fini
bref 3 kg 6e 5e samedi un truc c'est la
vitesse d'exécution de maxime on l'a
senti tout au tout au cours du match
mais mai 2000 gasquet a montré une telle
résistance en finale dans tous les
domaines de jeu il a quasiment pas
gaffer il était chaud quoi le délire peu
importe c'est juste ça va trop vite mais
bon maxime j'ai tellement vu souvent
joué en réel avec une minute contre 5 il
est injouable
je suis même pas sûr qu'on le battant
comme ça je faisais mais c'est vrai que
je percute mais qui s'affrontent sable
mazet j'ai vu que 2010 on compte mais
dit comme ça enfin c'est juste
il vient faire mal mais il voit vite
vite et bien ce qui va faire de la magie
en fait c'est un truc bizarre quand on
voit les xap par contre c'est que qu'on
joue en 5 contredit ou 3 pouces 2 ouais
ça changeait pas grand chose en fait je
vois qu'on joue en 5 minutes contre 2
minutes ou en 3 plus de ça a changé pas
énorme en fait les résultats
ce qu'en fait comme il calcule sur ton
temps et tous et qui calcule tellement
vite c'est pas par la différence c'est
pas si vous faites cher que donner un
handicap c'est pas pour la 5 1 oui mais
non mais c'est un gros truc tout simple
le même en russie + moi je sais pas ce
que je déteste jouer pour flâner en tête
ce serait une des seules chances là même
sans fausse pandémie joue vraiment vite
vite vite
mais les chiens
et puis plus cheap pour les matches à
ces vitesses de l'éclair le c5 les votes
le planteur
non mais ça change pas grand chose en
fait pour eux
faire planter ivoiriens que le cavaliere
en biologie mot de passe super bien
enfin superman mais qu'est ce qui a
comme idée g41 jours enfermé truies les
envies les mecs et 28 44 en bullet il
s'est défoncé vrai mais c'est un peu le
but est la vôtre nous faisons c'est là
où il nous est plus flou dans la
dimension qu'est bon ça va très vite
aussi en fait ça dépend des styles de
joueurs aussi quand tu plus technique et
tout à moins de répertoire c'est dur moi
je sens en bullet j'arrive pas de quoi
organiser dans l'ouverture des jo il ya
des mecs sont vraiment spécialiste du
bullet alors comme berck bartholomew
tout ça j'ai vraiment du mal ils ont
leur répertoire pour le bullet et où
quand tu quand même le pingouin ou quoi
mais disons que même contre un joueur
affronte maximo est vraiment trop fort
en bullet c'est plus facile des jeux
dans les cadences plus longue que tu as
le temps d'organiser quelque chose là tu
devais juste enchaîné et 200 points en
bullet ces normes la différence de
niveau
mais bon maxime pense qu'ils en 3d dû
l'être humain derrière amv elle était
derrière magnus est baghriche ou
caustique est pas mal mais sur
l'échiquier en fait soit que maintenant
les matches il était pas mal mais il
avait tenu maximum
oui mais bon après faut vraiment mature
son parti je ne sais pas pas sûr un
diplomate y est je suis pas sur internet
oui elle qu'il est plus lent c'est sûr
mais enfin c'est mon truc
chikhi atteinte à paris n'ont pas pu
venir planète
calme-toi à quoi bon c'est bon si tu le
dis que rem et 2d 3d quoi c'est pas les
choses non mais outre sa touche pas les
pièges des souris je sais pas ça pas
loin de chez lui un héros sens en tout
cas on a remarqué en pro chelsea vous
quoi que les mecs qui sont bons non non
c'était mon tout le monde on ne change
pas grand chose au maxime qui a un peu
relâché l'étreinte
bah voila il a fait le boulot il souffle
ouais mais ça peut il n'a pas plu adopté
non mais ça prouve que dominguez est bon
parce que sinon il reste un fait il n'a
jamais sombré quoi il a été moins fort
mais la majorité soit sûr que souvent tu
lâches le match evian fatigue se bat
tout le monde s'est bien reprise des
cistes kg 4
l'art est un genre de grinta non car je
respecte beaucoup cette attitude
personnellement j'ai un grand respect
parce que quand ça se passe mal
butt a envie de ce sinistre moi j'essaye
tout le temps aussi j'ai un peu ce truc
je sais vraiment maximum ne pas lâcher
mais ça c'est parce que comme j'ai
beaucoup joué au poker tu sais au poker
tu es obligé d'être comme ça parce que
tu as ta apte à jouer 18 apps est sorti
dix sept premiers tournois t'as pas un
gros stack mais pas tu as ça arrive
parfois que ce soit le tour à cuguen que
tard ce qui arrive et que ça ça m'est
déjà arrivé sur ce truc
il faut vraiment pas lâcher faut essayer
de mais c'est dur psychologiquement et
donc du coup je me suis entraîné à ça et
à peut-être par excès dans des camaïeux
5 et du coup j'ai un grand respect pour
pour les gens qui sont comme ça parce
que je sais à quel point c'est dur
là il peut revenir à -4 me y aura pas le
temps de remonter mais et maxime
qu'espoir ans qui joue pas la pendule
tu as eu pour essayer de jouer des coups
quand même green shoots le faire
d'ailleurs
finalement maxime qui a mis un coup
d'accélérateur mais qui d'enlever la
[ __ ] ouais merde et qui s'emploie plus
ben non mes doigts
non mais vraiment beau match franchement
c'est pas souvent qu'on a des beaux
matches comme ça c'était serré très
longtemps et il ya des belles parties
des belles finales vraiment sympa ce
match
reste qu à présidente du supermarché cet
état fait des 5 et cherche donc à rien
en plus écartée f34 un jour mais bon
sang je préfère les noirs parce que
perdre fou et dangereux tenue d'eve à
quelle vitesse et ignorer ce qu'elles
ont des trois impressions mais c'est
simple petit plat
non seulement cela dans une case à jouer
et s de l'éclair il a déjà la seconde de
retard c'est que je suis moins bon il a
ralenti maximale et les six toros de jeu
final c'est fini alors que c'était bien
sa partie la plus pentue un truc assez
sage temps d'avancé ça
non mais c'est bon c'est bon quoi
enfin faudra quand même élevé le débat
contre contre matin ça suffira pas ce
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui même c'était beau
que c'était maxime a fait un super match
contre contre hikaru ça suffira pas
fabre à l'avancé un énorme match on l'a
eu échos les deux dernières années non
contre contre hikaru il faudra il faudra
jouer mieux et plus vite et à pointe
c'est possible ou alors que ja rule que
hikaru cent pas dans un bon jour un
jeune homme non il est là moi c'est
encore une potion typique de maxime de
toit sont pures mois mais son sujet
cette affaire qui est français 1 franc
et 2 france 3 il peut déjà rasé mai
alors fabi reste il reste 3 minutes 32
matchs et on est à + 5
ouais donc une nouvelle fois
l'algorithme de mathématiquement fini
ces matériaux ont bien fini et le fou
s'est amplifié en l'air et avec les
professeurs il faut prendre le 5e y aura
plus de cases et maxime d'affaires +6 et
il va rester un parent qu il va rester
encore une ou deux parties docteur
support
le pauvre dominguez il ay leur a pas
baissé la tête hein est toujours plein
cam jean avons tout tenté jusqu'au bout
mais comme prévu le français était trop
fort après ils auraient pu avoir sa
chance contre un joueur un peu plus
faible dominguez ouais tu vas peut-être
contraint les bonnes qui est très fort
aussi mais qui est peut-être un peu
moins fort que maxime non ceux d'en haut
norma et il aurait pu au coeur d'un
conte carnage pense qu'il était
carrément favori 1 je pense qu'il vaut
mieux en lice que caruana pas de chance
au tirage pas de chance on n'a pas assez
dur contre les chocs au niveau cardiaque
contre duda priorité tête était au
dessus ouais ben haddou denrée rare on
apprend quand vous première fois qu'ils
jouent ce truc gémit un petit lien vers
la chaîne youtube si vous voulez suivre
et je mettais un petit nid russie vers
la chaîne twitch bitstream vu qu'on a vu
que ça touche à sa fin dont vous pouvez
suivre les deux chaînes si vous le
souhaitez ça permettra de vous les
conseille
bah oui oui de continuer à le suivre
plus toujours plus
alors
méfiant d'un qui peut battre n'a cassé
car avec innate peut-être oublié claria
king dans le truc de formats oui mais tu
disais le bullet parce que karine forret
mais peut-être plus fort aussi en vue
latin car et une ambulance il avait été
impressionnant mais les prêteurs
créature si tu es là dans les mecs qui
la fait pas perdre au premier tour
non je pense tu as vraiment envie de le
jouer en fait soit premier ou deuxième
il veut prendre sa 6ème tour assez fort
mais surtout radio je voulais changeant
des 8 ou ou si tu fais aussi du prenant
bien je veux te faire tourner comme la
mieux payée 600 euros la tonne cette
dame sert la mach 6 new york et 17 me
faro génez pas messieurs en haïtien
matin deux numéros h1 met du coup dans
le cadre de leur projet s'est toutefois
non au kilomètre bien joué
sont forts 1 et 2 mai
le mature mais officiellement finie fab
c'est la dernière partie
et ce serait sympa que s'affichent sur
une nulle quelques pas parce qu'on a
devant lui maxime la perdre
non on n'est pas très bien parti
cette dure à sauver cet homme mois soit
première rangée kefaya ça c'est un peu à
l'image du match quelque part c'est bien
joué tu me mets dont le clouage pour
planter le truc c'est waou après ce que
ça c'est vraiment nul chez eux
il a fait tellement vite maxime que
voilà oui mais il devait connaître
peut-être au f5
il aurait dû venir faire la master class
il a peur oui bah fallait faire un
master class avec nous pas enfin tu fais
5 tempo et fine je vois ce que j'ai dans
la master class m
aux techniques bah ouais mais enfin tu
as plein d'humour anglais font rares
fenêtres 5 dans le truc mais en surachat
fait tempo avec 5 et tu fais le petit
reprennent cette fois c'est vrai mais tu
as un truc qui peuvent paraître tout con
mais au final important quoi ça lui a
coûté la partie
bon bah fantastique un plus c'est tout
finalement
voilà un débat
bah c'est vous c'est un beau match
franchement je dois vous avez apprécié
c'était un très beau match
combien vaut un bon ça marche interview
ben je sais pas si vous m'aviez sur le
truc j'ai pas je reste là pour le moment
en ligne parce que je vais le prendre
sur zoom ou pas j'en sais rien match de
ce soir au sang chaud en plus en fait le
truc c'est que techniquement tu peux pas
ne peut pas su se mettre à rester cinq
minutes le temps que convoi civil soit
demain si l'on vient de faire
non mais je suis pas sûr qu'il fasse
enfin je sais pas je vais voir le voit
pas si ça se passera pas du fait de
maxime ou non c'est sûr à 2 après il est
un peu fatigué bien cum de beats et 3h30
j'ai finalement tableau d'échauffement
quand bienne et des tableaux
d'échauffement
finalement il a bien il a le bon
calendrier ok j'ai joué bienne
ap les deux buts viennent tous pris peur
fort de first first round of the speech
est symbolique du peu de signes que phil
cup
tout au plus peuvent fanfare de match
against nakamura quoi je pense que c'est
un peu ça son calendrier cette année en
espérant que ça marche ouais c'est vrai
tu vas caruana finalement les candidats
ça n'a pas ça n'a pas vraiment eu a mis
en route pour tient peut-être pas dû les
jouets quoi caruana
du coup ce qu'au final ce qu'au 17 10
soit 19 12
l'armée bravo à dominguez qui était un
adversaire de haut vol
mais bon ça sert à rien de gagner
facilement quoi plus le défi est grand
plus la victoire est belle vaincre sans
péril on triomphe sans gloire
ouais
la station de la dame de pique un petit
sachet pas ma tasse cid de corneille
nous ce qu'est ce que j'ai fait à
l'heure cet après midi j'étais chez moi
je me fais mais vu tu fais mes vidéos on
est bon je vais dormir ce que je sais
qu'il ya le match et tout d'un coup sans
aucune raison j'ai décidé de lire sur la
guerre franco-prussienne de 1870
mais c'est très intéressant en fait je
recommande situation wikipédia ou su
faire des recherches c'est la guerre 30
ans qui s'avère qui a duré six mois de
prison peut se regardent 30 ans et ça
fait la guerre de trente ans mais en
fait j'ai dit non mais là la proche de
bismarck est assez intéressante en fait
à un moment donné tu as une rencontre
entre un vin entre un ambassadeur et le
est un mec important chez les prudes
peut-être le roi quoi je peux pas jouer
c'est plus exactement tulsa tout à
l'heure mais il faut que je feins tu
vois j'ai pas fou est en fait le truc se
passe très bien l'ambassadeur français a
été très cordiale mais bismarck décide
de faire un truc de propagande et fait
semblant que le que l'ambassadeur
français a manqué de respect qu'il a
fumé importe car c'est pas du tout vrai
quoi du coup les français ses nerfs mais
c'est juste parce qu'ils voulaient pas
déclaré la guerre à la france sur et que
la france suit l'écart la guerre ce
qu'ils pensaient que dans son opinion
publique et tout ça il pourrait pas
vraiment réunir tous les toutes les
provinces allemande s'y déclarer la
guerre à tous va attaquer bon voilà
défendre la patrie du coup on fait des
courses à faire une dispense pas de
compagnon du coup les français très
énervé qui était très sûr en leurs armes
et se dit bon on va le défoncer mais en
fait c'est fait réagir on était moins
bien armé - nombreux mois entraînés fao
c'est un massacre s'adonner duré six
mois et encore ça aurait pu durer que
trois quoi
mais hier c'est tellement mal hein quoi
tu fais tiens il est de tourner
l'ambassadeur de la mer sur moi et tout
bon ben ce n'est pas vrai enfin tu
traînes très énervé que fait très
attention je raconte n'importe quoi mais
c'est hyper mal
nous sommes attaqués tout bas mais j'ai
trouvé très malin
mais en fait je connaissais bismarck tu
vois mais je ne savais pas vraiment
battus à ses faits d'armes
ouais mais du coup ça a été ça a été le
terreau d'un nationalisme français
revanchards ce qu'ils écrivent
et ces deux là en fait là revanchard 10
de la guerre de 14 18 par rapport aux
allemands au biskri non c'était après le
bep ce crime et du coup en fait le
résultat de la guerre de 14 18
en fait quand il enchaîne doula
revanchard 10 des allemands après en
fait tu vas tu vois que tu es un mec
hyper moteur on attend la suite
on vieillit très revanchard après très
fort en chat potté séville 82
mais c'est ce que dit pascal aussi
l'épisode de la dépêche dmc exactement
mais toi je suis pas spécialiste j'ai lu
genre et une heure cet après midi au
lieu de dormir puis après je me suis
endormi mais enfin fout pas je faillis
tous spécialistes du truc mais juste la
stratégie du mec m'a impressionné
qu'est-ce qu'il est malin
brison signé l'armistice et tout ça et
puis après voilà quoi
non mais je vais mieux me renseigner
pour les prochaines fois mais tu vois
par exemple je sais que vlad et magnus
eux s'il est dit dans une interview
qu'il s'intéresse à ces trucs là pour
progresser aux échecs et je sais que
vlad est un gros spécialistes genre si
tu lui parles de ça il va t'en parler
pendant des heures
il connaît très bien aussi indiqué que
les échecs mais quoi qu'il en soit ces
générations trouvé l'histoire enfin un
expert mais c'est cool en fait de savoir
que ça la tête tu vas il faut qu'on
fasse une chaîne histoire sont longues
il va en avoir beaucoup plus
intéressante mais un bogey mais qu'est
ce qu'on raconte aux couleurs de jeudi
réalisées par hélio jour de lire cette
année bonne chaîne nota bene tout ça qui
ont des bons trucs mais je trouve que
c'est plus intéressant de de lire un
plus intéressant mais on oublie de lure
n'ont ni pas assez enfin franchement
enfin vertu ni pas plus que moi non même
moins je pense pas du tout fouillé
reprise points non mais je sais pas
d'accord si belles paroles mais bon tu
peux pas partir coincé pas si
l'interview de l'autogare pour le monde
mais dans ce lieu à l'assurance turque
et monte a appris quelque chose là bas
tu tennis c'est intéressant cette fin de
ce crime bismarck jive un top-10 mart
avait dû l'art de la bière sûrement ça
c'était du 18 juillet 1960 10 au 29
janvier 1871
ayez un jour devrait deux périodes le
général masséna peuvent qui était très
chaud et gharib a lieu si l'un des deux
vous les deux
mais bonne nuit nabeul à ce style
pédagogique aujourd'hui le web quelque
part cette pédagogie mais sinon c'est
autre chose de ce qui arrive à liestal
italien te dis patate en juniors
mais je crois oui mais une amie n'était
italien mais je crois qu'il est venu
aider les rangs de l'armée française une
place à nice la porte au colisée je
crois qu'il est venu aider l'armée
française
à ce moment là mais bon je dis est âgée
est ce que c'était vraiment l'italie ou
le comté de gênes ou alors ils me
demandent maintenant il ya plus de
partie ce soir c'est fini le match mais
masséna sur mes placements
alors attends je vais récupérer mes
hélène donc fac je vais te laisser pour
le moment allez bonne écoute
à tout à l'heure en ce long cours en jeu
durant votre chatte
c'est un plus d'avoir ce match et fiba
eh bien on suivra les autres puis une
belle route maka en kart hockey à
l'étoile l'ocha donc on a fat qui est
parti on va essayer de récupérer mais
elle attend de les rejoindre
j'ai rejoindre
allo dany
salut maxime salut
c'était chaud tonton cette tâche est
vrai il était résistant le cubain enfin
il nous a fait suer quand on n'en
pouvait plus oui mais de toute façon
alors jetez pas j'étais évidemment pour
fatiguer du tournoi donc du coup et
c'était je n'ai pas très bien joué je
sens mais bon après j'ai quand même eu
pas mal de réussite d'un point même de
position que ce serait bien aidé à
rester aux au score jusqu'au jusqu'au
bout fait mais en fait c'est en gros le
match corrige - et c'est tout ce qu'on a
ressenti ce qu'au début en 5 + 1 c'était
chose c'est peut-être même moins bien
payés vrai que tu finisses devant jeu
parce que toi tu as ressenti
oui j'ai eu pas mal de réussite après je
pus vite le 6ème ouest a toujours joué
plus vite et là en fait le moment on a
eu peur qu'est ce qui s'est passé à la
pause en fait qu'est-ce que tu avais
pendant la pause qu'il est revenue et
poum direct - la pause moi je me suis
laisser un peu aller et puis bon c'est
vrai que c'est un peu le rythme est bon
je pourrais pas dire que je sais plus où
j'en ai perdu deux ou trois de suite net
a perdu deux de suite ouais ouais
et après tu as trouvé à un moment donné
c'est un truc avec kiev 4 août a donné
un pion de fêtards année tout cas y
arrive ça oui il est partout ouais ouais
non mais c'est sûr que de toute façon
cette laie n'était pas de manière
générale je pense pas avoir très bien
joué mais bon après encore une fois ils
promettent de partie où ça aurait pu
bien plus mal tourner et donc le match
aurait lieu
reconnaître encore plus chaussures c'est
vrai que en bullet était trop fort je ne
veux jamais joué contre tous en bullet
si jamais tu vois mon pseudo sur une
chaise comme un beauf tu me vois tu
annules le défi quoi du nombre je doute
pas le concept noir et non mais t'es
trop rapide cf
c'est insupportable quand tu fais des
poires des choses aussi vite je vous ai
passé ça c'est juste incroyable
ouais bon sauf que sauf que le prochaine
adversaire il joue encore plus vite
c'est ce qu'on dise un peu dans les
commentaires il nous fait un peu peur
aussi
je sais pas s'il y aura une stratégie
contre lui contre compte ricains ou non
pas spécialement le stratégie il faudra
juste être en forme et puis bien pouvoir
mais évidemment au moins tenir le score
jusqu'au boulette c'est le faire et
après une fois riz membres au bout net
voilà j'avais commenté deux derniers
matches contre lui
et j'avais l'impression que eux
c'étaient des matches très tactique en
fait ce que vous rendiez coup pour coup
en tactique c'est que des positions très
dynamique
est ce que tu penses que tu aurais pas
intérêt à jouer des choses un peu plus
fermé un peu plus stratégique
je sais pas après si vous le plus de
[Musique]
fois tu prends s'adapter faut être aussi
à prendre quelques risques
si je veux gagner le match mais de
toutes façons de faire faillite ou la
nage d'or avec les blancs il rentrait
dedans et où tu peux pas faire grand
chose d'autre et pas disons que tout
être le meilleur joueur du monde dans la
nasse d'or n'a aucun sens aucune raison
de ne pas faire
oui non non non aux quelles raisons bon
bah écoute tu sais qu'on sera le match
contre licka route à nancy je cède aux
dépens des autres joueurs
je pense qu ils se croient tous des
cuisses et 8e ok ok maxime bah écoute un
grand merci de venir répondre aux
quelques petites questions j'imagine que
tu es épuisé après ce match on va suivre
tes exploits à saint louis pour la sinne
que phil coke
on ne souhaite la même très bonnes
chances quoi pour ces tournois la merci
et
mais à bientôt coiffe un battoir fais
comme tu sais faire ça ok tout le monde
va écouter
merci à maxime d'être venu pour
l'interaction les cévennes au top et je
vous dis je vous dis à tous et à bientôt